So Leute, da bin ich zur Abwechslung mal, ähm, was ist heute überhaupt Mittwoch?
Donnerstag, Donnerstagabend am Start, ich weiß nicht ob heute MMO Kreiselcrime ist, kann sein, dass ich nachher weg muss
und ich dachte mir, ich mach mal am Anfang ein bisschen gescheite Musik an, bis das Stream richtig anläuft
Übrigens ein exzellenter Soundtrack, falls das Game jemand noch nicht gespielt hat, absoluter Pog Soundtrack
Massive Pog Soundtrack, wobei dann wahrscheinlich nicht jeder Bock drauf hat, könnte ich mir vorstellen
Ich mach auch gleich aus, wenn das Stream richtig angelaufen ist, aber ich dachte ich muss mal was
Gescheites sein, wir können nicht immer nur Nintendo gedudelt und sonst was haben
Ich muss mal was ordentliches, wo sind meine Mikrofon-Settings? Ich habe schon drei mal den Mixer aufgemacht
Perfekt
So was richtig, genau
Um auf fröhliches VM erstellen uns ein bisschen einzustimmen
Ich würde ja normalerweise mal ein bisschen was von meiner Lieblingsmusik anmachen
Das Problem ist, Monka Toss, ich kann nichts anmachen
Okay, ich glaube das Stream ist angelaufen, ich mach jetzt wieder etwas beruhigendere Klänge an
Was machen wir denn heute an?
Kontrast Programm
Also ich habe das Game nicht gespielt, muss ich sagen, aber das Spiel hat einen mega nice Soundtrack
Hat das jemand gespielt von euch, Metal Hellsinger?
Das ist quasi so ein Doom Rhythmus Game Verschnitt
Mit mega niceem Soundtrack
Die haben sogar den System of a Dawn Typ dabei hier
Song Modding, oh ja nice, da kann man tatsächlich seine Lieblingsmusik reinhauen
Es ist so dumm, dass die ganzen Mainstream-Sachen auf Twitch
Ich mache ein bisschen was beruhigenderes an
Es ist echt dumm, dass die ganzen Mainstream-Sachen auf Twitch mittlerweile angekommen sind
Und dass sie das gecheckt haben, dass es das gibt
Weil früher konntest du ohne Probleme auch Monka Toss-Musik laufen lassen
Heute ist Tag der Modges
Chat, Chat, einmal, es sind noch nicht viele da, ich weiß, ich weiß
Ihr müsst jetzt einmal in den Chat gehen und Mod-Check
Für die Mods
Wir brauchen jetzt einmal von allen die da sind
Ich weiß es sind noch nicht viele da, einmal Mod-Check für uns
Können wir nachher nochmal machen
Perfekt
So, machen wir mal ein bisschen was beruhigenderes an
Das ist mal Kontrastprogramm, oder?
Du musst es doch zu 100% fertig machen
Ich muss es mir vielleicht erstmal
Also, ich glaube, ich habe es sogar
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich es sogar gekauft habe
Aber ich habe es weder runtergeladen, noch gespielt
Es könnte, nee, nee, runtergeladen
Alles klar
Es ist eine Stadt in Dänemark
Gut
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich es gekauft habe auf Steam
Ja, richtig, richtig
Ich höre den Soundtrack
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, da höre ich oft den Soundtrack und spiele es nicht
Ich höre zum Beispiel auch richtig gerne noch
den Warcraft
und teilweise die World of Warcraft Soundtracks
auch wenn ich das überhaupt nicht spiele
Also, generell Blizzard-Musik aus den älteren Games
fand ich auch sehr nice
Also wenn man so ein bisschen auf so Orchester-Kram steht
Ja, es ist halt echt doof
dass
die ganzen Mainstream-Leute
jetzt auch auf Twitch
also die ganzen
Plattenfirmen und sonst was, dass die alle mitgekriegt haben, dass es Twitch gibt
Sonst hätte ich durchaus
Ich hab ja schon
Ich hab ja teilweise schon
Ich hab Glory Hammer mal angehabt
Die Ärzte hatten wir ein paar Mal an früher
Aber
Du kannst halt nichts mehr anmachen
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, bei den Ärzten
bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob da was passiert
Aber, ja
Also, es ist halt kacke
dass man
dass Twitch jetzt zu Mainstream ist
in der Richtung
Man hat keine Chance, hier irgendwelche
Monka-Toss-Musik zu spielen
Was ziemlich blöd ist
muss ich sagen
Ja, das ist aber auch doof
Da hast du ja wieder Riesenakt
Das ist halt kacke
Also, ich hätte gerne
ab und zu mal
hier bisschen Musik, die ich
Also, nicht so, dass ich mir das Nintendo-Gedudel nicht geben kann
aber ich hätte gerne auch mal ein bisschen ordentlich
was
was ich sonst auch offstream höre, mal ab und zu
im Stream angemacht, muss ich sagen
Ich will euch ja nicht hier beschallen mit Heavy Metal die ganze Zeit im Stream
Aber das kannst du nicht mehr machen
Ja, nee
Kannste nicht mehr machen
Ja, da könnte man mal ein bisschen Blind Guardian anmachen
oder so was
Irgendwas, was ich halt selbst gerne höre
Aber kannst du knicken hier im Stream
auf Twitch mittlerweile
Leider, ja
Ich weiß nicht, wie das manche machen
Ich hab das jetzt schon gesehen
Bei manchen Streamern, dass die so
0815 Mainstream-Musik laufen haben
Da weiß ich nicht genau, wie die das machen
Wahrscheinlich
haben die
Wobei sie persönlich nicht, aber die
die Agentur oder was auch immer
die die vertritt
oder dieses Management-Ding was die vertritt
Wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche Spezial-Abmachungen mit
irgendwelchen
ja, Verwertungs-Gesellschaften
oder so
Ja man, das bringt dir ja nichts
Du darfst den Kram ja trotzdem nicht
Ja, aber du darfst den Kram ja trotzdem nicht
nicht spielen
Es ist ja egal, ob es
ein Watt ist oder nicht, du darfst es ja auch
so und so nicht spielen
Gut, bei dem anderen reduziert sich die Chance
Da müssen sie dich quasi live erwischen
Aber trotzdem
Apple hat mich auch mal live erwischt vor Jahren
Wo ich die Apple-Konferenz
gestreamt hab und sie ein bisschen geflamet hab
Bam, Strike
Aber der Strike, Leute
Der Strike ist weg
Der Apple-Strike ist weg
Nach einer Weile ist Apple glücklicherweise
tatsächlich so großzügig gewesen
Mittlerweile darf man die Apple-Konferenzen streamen
Ich machs aber nicht mehr
Können wir nicht mal
Aber
Ja
Das haben sie dann
Zurückgenommen
Also quasi als es erlaubt war
Da haben sie wieder
Vor einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren
Haben sie das gelöscht
Das war ja auch nicht von Apple selbst
Das war ja von irgendeiner komischen
XY
Super teure Anwaltskanzlei
Die halt Apple vertritt
Es ist halt schon ein bisschen kacke
Ist wirklich doof
Wie das mit dem
Mit streamen und Musik
Zum Beispiel können wir ein bisschen Powerwolf anmachen
Ab und zu
Für richtige Prager-Time
Wenn mal irgendwas
Wenn mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert
Dann würden wir einfach eine Runde Praying im Chat
Ich würde Powerwolf anmachen
Und das ist dann so viel Prager
Prager-Overload, dann muss es eigentlich
Funktionieren
Aber kannst die ja nicht machen
Keine Chance
Ja vielleicht soll ich das auch machen
Vielleicht soll ich das auch
Vielleicht soll ich das auch einfach
Gut mit zweiter Tonspur
Dann können wir den VOD-Channel auf Youtube dicht machen
Weil
Wobei
Die laden das ja vom VOD runter und nicht live
Dann müsste ich tatsächlich
Eine zweite Tonspur mit Gedudel machen
Für ein VOD
Und
Hier im Stream könnten wir uns irgendwas
Härteres geben
Das ist eine gute Idee
Also besser gesagt
Ich würde ja eh nicht im Stream jetzt
Allzu viel
Sei es Powermetal
Oder generell irgendwie
Hättere Musik machen, ich weiß, dass da viele nicht drauf stehen
Ich halt schon
Ab und zu wird es halt auch gut passen
Du kannst halt nichts anmachen
Übrigens
Soll ich euch mal was zeigen
Ich mach mal kurz die VM an
VMG
Virtualisierungsge
So also
Zu starten
Ich mach mal meine normalen Linux VM an
Ich zeige euch mal was
Und zwar die Playlist, die fuckt mich jedes Mal ab
Weil sie ungleichmäßig laut ist
Mal ist sie laut
Mal ist sie leise
Bisschen zu laut
Ich brauch mal ein bisschen
Busy was Zackigeres heute
Mal wenigstens mal Crypt of the Necrodancer
Das ist auch pogger Soundtrack
Das ist auch ein mega nice
Game beziehungsweise mega nice Soundtrack
Wenn man auf sowas steht
So
Also ich mach mal die VM an
Und ich zeige euch mal was
Guck mal
Wir gehen jetzt mal auf die GitHub-Seite
Vom VM-Champ
Und ihr werdet feststellen
Achtet mal hier drauf
Es gibt seit 2 Stunden Version 2
Ha
Stell euch mal vor
Version 2
Beziehungsweise
Ne ne ne
0.0.2
Kurz runterladen
Und hier hin kopieren
Dass ich euch ein bisschen was zeigen kann
Bevor wir uns dann TrueNAS angucken
Repos
Scripts
Da muss es rein
Exzellent
Wir machen da heute gar nichts mit
Wir machen heute TrueNAS
Wir gucken uns heute TrueNAS-Scale an
Aber ich kann das auch kurz zeigen
Wir haben ja Zeit
Eventuell
Noch ist keiner da
Vielleicht gibt es nachher wieder Kreiselcrime
Muss ich mal gucken
So ich mach mal kurz hier
Terminal zu
Dann machen wir einfach mal
Package Updates
Und starte
Starte neu
Das verdammte Spiel
Wie PNPM
Kann das heute vielleicht
Okay
Ich mach mal nichts während das eine läuft
Es ist eh ein Kernel Update dabei
Wenn Kernel Update dabei ist heißt ich muss auf jeden Fall
Rebooten
Warum streamst du den Kreiselcrime nicht
Weil ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute Dark Edge of Camelot
Nicht so spannend finden
Ich hab ja ein paar Mal R4R gestreamt
Das kam erstaunlich gut an
Ich mein es ist halt ein uralt Game
Und die meisten haben da glaub ich keinen Bock drauf
Außerdem will ich ein bisschen
Mit den Leuten schwätzen
Und mich nicht so sehr auf den Stream konzentrieren
Das ist richtig was Tribes schreibt
Nur um neue zu erstellen
Warte mal ich kann dir das gleich zeigen
Wir rebooten jetzt mal
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann ich nicht
Das hatte ich ja noch nie
Das Reboot einen Lack hatte beim ausführen
Und jetzt hängt irgendwas
Ah ja da müssen wir mal kurz warten
Ob das sich von alleine beendet
Wenn es sich nicht von alleine beendet
Dann muss ich die VM halt abschalten
Ausschalten
Force Off
Und kann ich euch noch was anderes
Erzählen
No Limit
Ja wir warten mal kurz
Eine Minute können wir warten wenn nicht
Bisschen Steuerung C hemmern
Ich kann euch noch was lustiges erzählen
Ich hatte ja am Mittwoch meinen letzten Arbeitstag
New World
Let's Play Monkeys Alter New World
Ich hatte ja letzten Mittwoch
Gestern
Das hört sich jetzt zum letzten Mittwoch
Gestern war das
Letzter Mittwoch
Ja mach noch Github rein
Also ich hatte gestern
meinen letzten Arbeitstag
Und da habe ich meine ganze Hardware zurückgegeben
Das waren ja insgesamt zwei Notebooks
Das Handy
Tassatur
Maus ganz ganzes Geschiss
Alles was ich hatte
So Docking Station
Curved Monitor
Alle Dinge alle Sachen
Zurückgegeben
Ich hatte das Netzteil für mein iPhone nicht dabei
Ach guck mal jetzt
Jetzt hat es funktioniert mit Ausschalten
Ich hatte das Netzteil für mein iPhone nicht dabei
Also dieses billige
Das ist nicht billig das ist Apple
Das kostet ja 50 Euro
Das USB-C Netzteil
Von meinem iPhone
Dann haben die gemeint ah sie wollen das eigentlich
Lieber komplett
Sie wollen das jetzt so eigentlich nicht
Sie wollen das lieber mit Netzteil haben
Habe ich gesagt heute ist mein letzter Arbeitstag
Das ist ja auch so
Ja dann geben sie es jetzt doch her
Ich mein hey die hätten auch sagen können
Ja dann fahren sie gefälligst heim
Und holen sie den Kram ja
Aber da wollten sie dann keinen Stress machen
Das fand ich witzig
Das können wir eigentlich so nicht nehmen da fehlt das Netzteil
Ja es ist mein letzter Tag ich kann es einfach auch wieder mitnehmen
Ah ne ne nee geben sie es einfach her
Aber ich meine scheiß auf dieses Netzteil man
Was wollen die damit vor allem
Die haben die Geräte selbst irgendwo geleast
Also insofern ist doch scheiß egal
So
Ja gut es ist ein Apple Netzteil
Was kostet okay lass uns das mal kurz
Lass uns das mal kurz
Kontrollieren
Apple USB-C Netzteil
Dafür kriegst du ja schon 3 China-Chinesen
Netzteile man
Ich hab mir letztens in den China-Chinesen
Achso ich hab mich verguckt
Moment Moment Moment
Das ist tatsächlich ein anderes
Das ist nicht das richtige
Das ist das falsche
Das sieht tatsächlich anders aus
Das andere ist aber auch nicht billiger
Das hier ist glaube ich das richtige
Ja das ist das richtige kostet aber auch 40 Euro
Das kostet aber auch 40 Euro
Das kostet aber auch einfach
Das kostet aber auch einfach 40 Euro
Ich hab mir letztens in China-Chinesen
Netzteile gekauft 140 Watt
Netzteil USB-C
Oh Alter
Warum ist das scheiß auf einmal so
Teuer Ich glaube
Ich hab mir das Netzteil gekauft
Aber
Garantiert nicht für 80 Euro
Ich kann jetzt, egal
Das fand ich tatsächlich ganz nice
Weil du kannst insgesamt 3 Geräte
Vor der Pulle daran laden
Du hast 2x USB-C, kannst darauf Lightning
Oder halt
Oder halt USB-A Anschluss
Aber bisschen teuer ist es trotzdem
So
So ja gut
Vor allem ist es neu gestartet
Ich hab bis heute
Kein USB-C Netzteil
Naja die neuen Netzteile
Die alle ein bisschen mehr Leistung haben
Die sind meistens mit mindestens einem USB-C ausgestattet
Das heißt man hat dann
Einen USB-C Netzteil
Man kann es auch mit einem USB-C ausgestattet haben
Das heißt man hat dann
Einen USB-C Netzteil
Man kann es auch mit einem USB-C ausgestattet haben
Man kann ja USB-C immer noch
Auf alles andere umwursten
Was du willst
Du kannst USB-C auf Mini
Mikro
Lightning
USB-C auf
USB-C soll es auch geben
Kannste eh alles machen
Es gibt sogar mittlerweile Kabel
Die sind ganz nice, die haben hinten einen USB-Stecker
Und auf der anderen Seite kannst du auswählen
Zwischen Lightning
USB-C
Also dreifach Kabel
Da hab ich immer eins
Im Rucksack dabei
USB-C
Kabel
Mikro-USB
USB-C und
Lightning
Nee, nee, nee
Sowas in der Richtung
Es ist nicht wirklich genau das
Aber sowas in der Richtung ist das
Da hast du hinten USB-C oder normales USB
Und vorne kannst du dir halt aussuchen
USB, USB-C oder Lightning
So eins hab ich immer dabei im Rucksack
Das ist enorm praktisch
Mit einer Powerbank
Weil ich hab keinen Bock mehr
Dass ich mal in der doofen Situation dann mal mach
So viel mittlerweile mit seinem Handy
So viele Informationen und wichtige Sachen drauf
Sei es auch Navigation
Mit dem Handy, wenn du irgendwo bist
Wo du dich nicht auskennst
Deswegen hab ich immer
12.000 mAh
Powerbank
Im Rucksack
Die du zur Not auch über
Solar aufladen kannst
Auch wenn das
Fragwürdig ist wie schnell das geht
Das hab ich noch nie ausprobiert
Ja sowas ist auch nicht schlecht
Also
OK
So also ich hab neu gestartet
Dann würd ich sagen
Ich zeig euch mal die neue Version vom VmChamp
Vom Anfang
Und mir ist das Musik zu nervös
Ich muss doch wieder
Entspannte Mario Klänge anmachen
Sonst wird das nix
Kann ich mich nicht konzentraten
Exzellent
Du du du du du du du
Ja OK das ist auch beste
Ich mach das übrigens auch gerne
Ich hab das teilweise sogar solche Playlists
Bei mir auf der Arbeit auf dem Kopfhörer an
Weil ich das einfach sehr entspannt finde
Nintendo Musik
Man kommt als Lebensraum als nächstes
Also entweder entweder als nächstes
Oder ich lass mich tatsächlich
Ich mach das immer zwischenzeitlich zum Abschalten
Von Bad Company 2 aus das glaub ich aber nicht
Ich glaub also entweder als nächstes
Oder als übernächstes
Ich mein ich muss jetzt mal langsam machen
Ich fang nächste Woche Montag an
Da wirds mal Zeit dass ich euch zumindest mal die Bewerbung alles zeige
Das ist ja das ist tatsächlich so
Wenn man das macht
Was?
Heute letzter Tag oder Morgen?
Gestern
Gestern ich hab alles abgegeben
Ich bin auch alles losgeworden
Also ich hab
Kein Handy mehr, kein Notebook mehr
Ich könnte mich theoretisch
Remote noch einloggen aber wozu sollte ich das
Wozu sollte ich das machen
Hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
Ich könnte theoretisch noch in Teams gucken aber wozu sollte ich das machen
Mach ich nicht
Bin weg
Wie fühlt sichs an?
Sehr merkwürdig im Prinzip
Im Prinzip so wie ich das gesagt hab
In dem
In meinem letzten Video
Sehr merkwürdig
Also
Aktuell
Aktuell bin ich im Kopf eher noch so
Als hätt ich zwei drei Tage Urlaub
Und
Nee
Bis jetzt hat es noch nicht hingehauen
Mit uns
Den zweiten Teil des Videos aufzunehmen
Wie ist es arbeitslos zu sein
Ich bin ja nicht arbeitslos
Also wenn man so will schon
Aber mein Arbeitsvertrag läuft
Ja noch bis zum 31.3
Und ab dem 1. läuft der neue
Also ich bin wahrscheinlich so
Die
Nanosekunde zwischen
Und dem Umschalten hier dazwischen mal kurz
Arbeitslos
Aber den Verlust bei der Rente werde ich überleben
Es ist sehr merkwürdig
Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr merkwürdig
Also im Kopf ist es bei mir jetzt so
Ich denke die ganze Zeit noch
Ich hab jetzt einfach
Urlaub bis nächste Woche so
Und dann gehts bestimmt weiter
Aber es geht halt nicht weiter
Was ja auch gut ist
Ich hab mir das ja absichtlich ausgesucht
Dass es nicht weiter geht
Ich hätte ja weiter machen können
Und was ich heute noch erfahren hab
Was mich auch
Was mich auch wieder zu der
Ja bekomme ich
Weil ich fette
Stonks hab
Also die gesetzliche Rente kannst du vergessen
Bei mir
Aber ich hab Stonks
Und ich hab noch
Die letzten Jahre
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge gemacht
Wo beide Seiten eingezahlt haben
Und das lohnt sich tatsächlich
Weil du kriegst ja quasi das
Was du einbezahlst noch mal mindestens verdoppelt
Vom Arbeitgeber
Und das hat sich gelohnt
Außerdem hab ich ein Haus
Außerdem hab ich genug Kohle
Ich hab Stonks
Also ich glaube Rententechnik ist bei mir nicht so das Problem
Aber gesetzliche Rente kannst du wahrscheinlich
Wissen, ja
Hast du deine Arbeitszeugnis?
Ja, sie haben es hinbekommen
Sie haben es endlich hingekriegt
Am letzten Tag konnte ich abholen
Ja
Also ich werd garantiert nicht bis 67 oder so
Arbeiten
Irgendwas muss man ja auch mal von seiner Kohle haben
Muss man irgendwann auch mal was von machen
Ja, also wie gesagt
Das ist sehr merkwürdig
Aber nächste Woche geht es ja schon wieder los
Da ist ja nicht so viel Zeit
Sich Gedanken drüber zu machen
So
Ich wollt grad noch irgendwas sagen
Zu irgendeiner Chatnachricht
Aber
Ich weiß es nicht mehr
Darüber auch ein Video
Was über meine Rente und Stonks
Boah ich weiß nicht, ich glaub da bin ich nicht der Richtige
Da großartig was zu Stonks zu erzählen
Zumal meine Stonks dieses Jahr
Ähm
Naja
Wenn ich nicht so geil war
Aber über das Arbeitzeugnis
Ja das könnt ich alles in einem machen
Achja genau, sehr gut
Chat, ich muss sagen
High IQ Chat
Man sieht die ganzen Prime Subscriptions zahlen sich eindeutig aus
Also die Hirnleistung des Chats
Also würde ich schon sagen
Dass das eindeutig auch Chat-GPT übersteigt
Die hätten sich eigentlich
Die hätten sich eigentlich sparen können
Diese ganze AI Entwicklung
Die hätten einfach auf den Wubblos Twitch Chat zurückgreifen müssen
Aber das wussten die halt nicht
Richtig
Weird Champing für die
Ich hab jetzt die Millionen reingesteckt
Und in Wirklichkeit haben wir schon längst was besseres
Gut, also ja dazu wollte ich was sagen
Korrekt
Du wolltest was sagen was du an deinem letzten Tag erfahren hast
Nee nee nee nee nee
Nicht am letzten Tag
Heute tatsächlich, heute mein letzter Tag war ja gestern
Heute hab ich das noch erfahren und zwar
Hab ich erfahren, dass
Oder da bin ich wieder zu dem Schluss gekommen
Dass ich da genau zur richtigen Zeit
Abgehauen bin
Und zwar was ich heute erfahren habe ist
Dass noch zwei weitere Kollegen
Wohl gekündigt haben
Und ich hab jetzt schon Probleme dass das alles
Aufrecht zu erhalten
Und wenn dann noch zwei weitere fehlen ist es komplett vorbei
Kann es komplett knicken
Es klappt jetzt nicht mehr
Und dann ist es komplett unmöglich
Ich sag mal ich sag nicht dass ich mich jetzt freue
Es ist nicht möglich dass es da den Bach runter geht
Das stimmt nicht
Weil ich kenne ja immer noch genug Leute die dort arbeiten
Und ja
Wo ich nicht will dass es denen jetzt
Tag täglich beschissen geht
Aber man sieht also
Ich komme immer wieder zu dem Schluss
Es war genau der richtige Zeitpunkt abzorn
Rennen alle Entwickler weg
Nee Entwickler rennen auch weg
Also ich hab gehört das letztes Jahr
Ende letzten Jahres angeblich
Ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt
Also wie gesagt wir hatten es um 5 wecken gehört
Über 100 Leute
Oder sagen wir mal
Abgerundet 100 Leute
Um die 100 Leute gekündigt haben
Ende letzten Jahres
Das ist extrem viel für den Laden
Normalerweise wurde es die letzten Jahre eher immer nur mehr
Aber gut man
Management fail einer nach dem anderen
Da muss man sich nicht wundern wenn das so
Wenn das so bergab geht
Man hat es ja auch kommen sehen
Es ist jetzt nicht dass es
Von heute auf morgen irgendwie
Auf einmal da gewesen wäre
Kann man jetzt liegen?
Nö ich liege das nicht ich liege das auch in Zukunft nicht
Worum soll ich das machen?
Ja also wie gesagt das habe ich
Das habe ich erfahren dass jetzt noch zwei weitere
Leute abhauen dann ist komplett komplett vorbei
Also gut
Dann können wir jetzt mit dem weitermachen was ich euch jetzt zeigen wollte
Bevor wir uns Tunas angucken
Dann erzähle ich euch auch warum wir uns Tunas angucken
Kann mir fix einer helfen
Und mir sagen wie das Video mit dem neuen Dateienndung
Hack heißt
Boah
Ich habe gedacht ich habe es vielleicht in der History
Ne keine Ahnung mehr
Keine keine Ahnung mehr
Ich meine du kannst einfach ins Wort gucken
Du kannst ins Wort gucken und durch skippen bis
Du es gefunden hast weil dann sieht man ja die Url vor Video
Beziehungsweise siehst du auch den Titel und dann kannst du den Titel einfach so
Ja das ist es
Ja das ist es genau
Alter Mordge wird ja wirklich
Way too high IQ
Mordges wissen's
Der Streamtitel
Ist ein bisschen bait keine Ahnung
Ich habe
Tunas Scale noch nie ausprobiert
Aber ich sehe
Im Heimbereich dass ganz viele Leute
Unrate, Tunas
Tunas weniger
Proxmox und Unrate verwenden
Und Tunas ja selber sagt
Sie machen ja
Webinterface für Shares erstellen
Und Disk Handling und sowas
Aber auch Container und VMs
Also ist das schon
Konkurrenz
Ich denke so
So würden die sich selbst auch sehen
Aber
Und das beste ist ja das ist richtig nice
Deswegen läuft Docker out of the box mit allem
Linux Geschiss drauf
Ja das ist nice also übrigens auch der Grund warum ich mir das jetzt nochmal
Angucke
Also bevor wir anfangen
Mit Tunas ich habe heute eine neue Version
Released vom VMCham
Und der Radio
Radio?
Wie hieß er denn? Radiosignal oder sowas?
Wo ist er?
Ach keine Ahnung
Hatte eben auch gefragt was macht das Tool deswegen zeige ich es euch
Ach da Radiosignale
Ich war doch gar nicht so schlecht mit Radio
Deswegen zeige ich es euch nochmal kurz
Und mit dem Hinweis es gibt jetzt
Es gibt jetzt Version 2
Es gibt übrigens auch bald ich habe mir vorhin schon eins
Erstellt
Ein Arch Repo dafür
Also der Vorti hat eins erstellt
Und ich erstelle jetzt noch ein Binary Repo
Da kann man sich das
Über den Arch Package Manager installieren
Genau ich habe vorhin Version 2
Gepusht was ist neu?
Was ist neu?
Es ist übrigens ich habe noch was vergessen
rein zu schreiben
Recreate
Option
On
Recreate
Override
Ich werde mal das jetzt richtig schreiben
Override Option
On
VM Start
Update
Wie viel Stars? 24
Erst noch
Da gibt es ein paar Neuigkeiten dazu
Habe ich heute Vormittag mich ein bisschen drum gekümmert
Ich dachte mir ich habe ja jetzt 2 Tage
Beziehungsweise inklusive dem Wochenende 4 Tage
Sonst nichts großartig zu tun
Können wir ein bisschen Progressstells machen muss ich auch nicht
Im Stream machen da geht es auch schneller
Dann kriege ich auch was auf die Reihe
Weil im Stream ist es immer schwierig da
Da bin ich so viel am schwätzen da kriege ich kaum was auf die Reihe
Das ist immer sehr schläffend und langsam
Im Stream was zu programmieren
Aber es geht halt nicht so schnell wenn man alleine vom Rechner sitzt
Also ich habe ein paar Sachen eingebaut
Man kann VMs jetzt neu starten
Wenn man eine VM anlegt
Die es schon gibt zeige ich euch gleich
Dann kann man die überschreiben
Man kann Customs Scripts ausführen
Nach dem erstellen der VM
Man kann die CPU Cores customise wie man will
Es gibt jetzt mehr Distribution zur Auswahl
Und man sieht im List Command
Ein bisschen mehr Option
Also was ist das für ein Tool
Auch wenn wir da heute nicht dran weiter programmieren
Das ist was was ich die letzte Woche im Homeoffice erstellt habe
Ja wie gesagt
Meine Motivation auf der aktuellen Arbeit hielt sich in Grenzen
Zumal man sagen muss
Das ist ein Tool was natürlich auch jedem Linux Admin nutzt
Deswegen gar nicht mal so schlecht investierte Zeit
Snapshots erstellen
Das Problem bei Snapshots erstellen
Ich glaube ich bin mir nicht sicher warum es nicht geht
Ich glaube das kann man nicht mit temporären VMs machen
Ich habe mir das aber schon als To-Do aufgeschrieben
Ob ich das nicht irgendwie einbauen kann
Weil ab und zu werden Snapshots zumindest auch temporär ganz praktisch
Aber ich glaube das funktioniert mit temporären VMs nicht
So also wie gesagt
Ich habe jetzt Version 2
Nicht zu laut sagen
Sollen sie die Rechte einfordern
Goodluck Herr Pfannen
So und ich habe das letzte Woche programmiert
Und das ist ein Tool
Man sieht es ja hier im Bild
Das ist ein Tool wo man
Lokal auf seine Linux Kiste
Mit einem Kommando
Sie schnell Test VMs erstellen kann
Manchmal braucht man
Echte VMs
Natürlich wenn man eine Test VM will
Kann man auch einfach hier in der Workstation gehen
New Virtual Machine weiter weiter weiter
ISO einhängen installieren
Aber das dauert halt
Da braucht man dann auch eine
Da brauchst ja 5-10 Minuten
Bis du ein fertiges Betriebssystem hast
Was funktioniert und ich will da halt
5-20 Sekunden drauf warten
Dann soll es da sein
So ähm
Du hast doch wieder
VM-Champ geworden
Das Tool nutzt nicht VM
Nein das geht mit KVM
Was ist für KVM steht ja auch hier
KVM QEMO lib wird
Known Boxes ist auch nichts
Weil es ist ein GUI Tool
Will auf der Kommandozeile VMs erstellen
Und mich direkt per SSH verbinden
Warum VMs ganz einfach
Weil nicht für alles ein
Container immer
Das beste ist zum testen
Zum Beispiel
Der offensichtlichste Fall ist
Wenn du
Kernel Module laden willst
Oder anloaden willst oder irgendwas testen willst
Das kannst du in jeglicher Containerlösung
Vergessen
Bist du nachher
LXC erklären? Ne
Ich mach nix mit LXC hier
Du meinst mal Tuners
Ich hab mir Tuners noch nie angeguckt
Was ist denn bei deiner
Bar oben der lange
Underscore Strich
Das ist Debutauslastung
Ich hab 8 Kerne ich zeig dir das mal
Ich mach mal ein bisschen Last
Ich geb mal einfach in meinem Terminal Yes aus
Guck dir mit
Ich hab 8 Kerne
Und die Kerne sind dann unterschiedlich ausgelastet
Jetzt haben wir ne schöne gleichmäßige Auslastung
Wie du auch hier siehst
Also hier haben wir jetzt CPU Auslastung
Hier oben siehst du halt CPU Auslastung
Dass das tatsächlich funktioniert
Kann ich dir auch daran zeigen
Wir machen mal 2 hoch
1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,8 nach BC
Wie?
Ich hab BC nicht installiert
Seriously?
Warum das denn nicht?
Guck jetzt berechnen wir was in BC
Und du siehst es ist auch nur ein CPU Core
Das IOU im Terminal dann schnell genug
Um CPU Auslastung zu haben
Na klar
Ich mein
Der IOU ist ja im Prinzip nur
Durch CPU
Belastbarkeit beschränkt
Und vielleicht ein bisschen GPU
Jaja klar
Wenn du so schnell wie geht
Im Terminal Sachen ausgibst
Dann macht das auch CPU Last
Ist zwar eine ziemlich sinnlose Sache
Um CPU Last zu erzeugen, aber ok
Du siehst es ist nur ein CPU Kern
Wir können übrigens auch S
Dings hier verwenden
Für Stresstest
Stresstest
100% CPU Auslastung
Auf allen Kurs
Aber man sieht das halt schlecht
Deswegen mach ich das lieber mit BC
Da kann man nämlich auch mal ein paar Sachen in den Hintergrund schicken
So eine CPU voll ausgelastet
Zwei CPUs voll drei
Vier CPUs voll ausgelastet
Siehst du genau hier
Das ist tatsächlich
Und jetzt können wir noch Terminal auslasten
Jetzt ist es gut ausgelastet
Ja ist eine nice Anzeige
Weil ganz im Ernst normalerweise
Interessiert dich ja gar nicht so genau
Welche CPU jetzt wie ausgelastet ist
Wenn du das genau wissen willst machst du H-Top auf
Oder wie die coolen Leute machen B-Top
Weil das viel cooler aussieht
Und das alle
Dann immer geil finden
Wenn man sich B-Top angucken kann
Aber ich muss sagen H-Top ist für mich immer noch beste
Und ansonsten willst du ja eigentlich
Nur wissen ob viel abgeht im Hintergrund
Auf deinem Rechner oder nicht
Und da ist die Anzeige hier oben ganz optimal aus
So
Aber kommen wir jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
Zurück dazu
Was man damit machen kann
Also im Prinzip ist es ganz einfach
Achja ich wollte ja noch eine Sache sagen
Manchmal ist es halt so
Man braucht immer noch lokal eine VM zum testen
Weil es ein Docker-Container eben nicht macht
Zum Beispiel
Offensichtlich siehst du Colonel-Module laden
Das kannst du halt mit Container-Lösungen nie machen
Weil das alles immer
Nur quasi ein weiterer Prozess
Im Host-Betriebssystem Colonel ist
Also Container sind ja
Eine Illusion wenn du es so willst
Container ist ja
Kein Container in dem Sinn
Container hört sich tatsächlich an
Wie so eine eigene Box
Na doch eine eigene Box trifft es eigentlich ganz gut
Aber es ist jetzt kein eigenes System
Auch wenn es auf den ersten Blick so aussieht
Ein Container ist stinknormaler Prozess
Wie jeder andere Prozess auch
Also wenn ich jetzt das hier
Also wenn ich jetzt hier meine Berechnungen starte
Auf meinem Host
Oder ob ich die in einem Docker-Container starte
Ist es vollkommen egal
Das ist kaum ein Unterschied
Für mein Host-Betriebssystem
Was es macht
Der Unterschied ist nur
Dass es ein paar
Container ist a lie quasi
Der einzige Unterschied ist
Der einzige Unterschied ist zwischen
So ausführen oder dieses ganze Ding
In irgendeinem Docker-Run ausführen
Ist, dass es ein paar
Sandboxing-Funktionen
Wobei das fast auch schon
Ein Tick viel gesagt ist
Ein paar Sandboxing-Funktionen gibt
Dass sich Prozesse
Nicht in die Quere kommen
Zum Beispiel
Dass die
Was haben wir da alles
Der Host-Name
Beispielsweise
Für jeden Prozess anders sein kann
Die Disk ein bisschen anders sein kann
Für jeden Prozess
Die Uhrzeit glaube ich sogar auch ein bisschen anders sein kann
Also es gibt ein paar vorgefertigte Namespaces
Nennt sich das in Linux
Also Container gibt es eigentlich
In dem Sinn nicht
Container sind eine Zusammenfassung
Aus zwei Features im Linux-Körner
Auch wenn das unter Container läuft
Das sind Cgroups und das sind Namespaces
Cgroups
Ist die
Sandboxing-Funktionalität
Wobei ich mir auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin
Was genau alles jetzt zum Aufgabengebiet
Von Cgroups
Cgroups 2 ist das ja mittlerweile Feld
Also Cgroups ist so ein bisschen
Das Sandboxing-System
Und Namespaces ist das
Um Prozessen in Containern
Andere Sachen vorzugaukeln
Als sie eigentlich auf dem Host sind
Zum Beispiel
Der Hostname
Die Uhrzeit und solche Geschichten
Aber Container in dem Sinn gibt es nicht
Das ist eine Zusammenfassung aus Features
Im Linux-Körner
So und es ist kein Unterschied wirklich
Großartig ob ich den Prozess in einem
Docker-Container ausführe
Oder hier
Lokal auf der Shell ausführe
Das macht kaum den Unterschied
Das läuft alles als Prozess
Hier auf meiner Host-Kiste
Und fertig
Deswegen
Wenn du
Wenn du Docker-Container startest
Als Route zum Beispiel
Da würde ich mich nicht auf die Sandbox-Funktionalitäten
Verlassen, dass da nichts passieren kann
So und deswegen
Gehen halt manche Sachen nicht
Nachdem jeder Prozess
Halt innerhalb
Meines Host-Betriebssystems läuft
Verwenden die auch alle den Körner
Von meinem Host-Betriebssystem
Also in dem Fall ist es
Und wenn ich
In einem Container Körnl-Module laden
Und entladen will, dann geht das nicht
Beziehungsweise
Ich könnte das machen
Auf dem Host
Und dann wäre es halt für alle Container da
Also es ist
Manche Sachen sind blöd im Container
Was auch blöd ist in Containern zu testen
Zum Beispiel ist
Systemd, Unitfiles
Und solche Geschichten, also wenn ich wirklich
Das starten will wie ein vollständiges
System, zumindest mit Docker ist es
Ein bisschen schwierig, du kannst so was
Mit LXC machen, wenn du komplette
OS-Images bootest, aber selbst da
Hast du ein paar Probleme
Also wenn du solche Sachen machen willst, sind
Container manchmal nicht die beste Wahl
Für 90% von
Lass mal die Anwendung bauen
Lass mal die Anwendung testen oder sowas
Dann
Ist Container eine super
Geschichte, weil es ist zackig, es ist schnell
Es braucht nicht viel RAM
RAM-Overhead ist ja der hauptsächliche
Knackpunkt an VMs
Also sagen wir mal, Disk und
RAM-Overhead, CPU ist gar nicht
So das Problem, die CPU-Leistung
In einer VM ist
Nahezu gleich
Zum Hausbetriebssystem
Was an der VM doof ist, ist
Dass eine VM RAM braucht
Also deutlich mehr RAM
Ich meine, guckt mal, wenn ich jetzt
Meine Berechnung hier ausführe
Dann brauche ich RAM genau für diese zwei
Befehle, beziehungsweise was PC an
RAM braucht zum Berechnen, sind paar Kilobyte
Wahrscheinlich unter der Haube, wenn ich das
Gleich in eine VM starten will
Da muss ich ja ein komplett
Neues
Linux booten, inklusive eigenem
Kernel, eigenen Libraries
Eigenem
User-Tools, alles mögliche
Dementsprechend ist das eigentliche
Problem an VMs
Nicht so sehr die CPU-Leistung, auch wenn das
Manche Leute denken, das eigentliche Problem
An VMs ist, warum es im großen
Stil nicht so der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss ist, ist schlicht und ergreifend
Die
Speicherauslastung
Also der Speicherverbrauch
Du brauchst halt viel viel mehr Speicher
Und halt auch für dein Image brauchste
Speicher
Das ist halt ein Unterschied
Demian Server mit 34 MB
RAM Verbrauch, ja, das sind
Aber du siehst, das ist quasi eines der
Minimalsten Systeme, die du laufen lassen kannst
Brauchen mindestens
34 MB in der VM
Mein Kommando hier zum Laufen zu lassen
Braucht 500 Kilobyte
Und das ist halt ein riesen Unterschied
Wenn du viele davon ausführen willst
So, und das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem
An VMs, oder was heißt das Hauptproblem
Also so eines der
Ja, Probleme, die man
Bekommt, wenn man
Im großen Stil VMs benutzt
Das ist halt im Vergleich zu Container einfach der
Overhead, was Speicher anbetrifft
Zu Disk, als auch Arbeitsspeicher
Es gibt ein paar
Bestrebungen dazu, das
Noch weiter zu verbessern, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
Kennt, Firecracker VM
Ich glaube, das ist irgendwas von Amazon
Das sind nochmal besonders
Minimalistische VMs
Allerdings, ich muss sagen, VMs werden
Dadurch, dass du einen eigenen Kernel starten musst
Immer mehr RAM verbrauchen als ein Container
Und deswegen, das ist halt eines der
Vorteile von Containern
Beziehungsweise Nachteile von VMs
Dafür haben VMs andere Vorteile
Erstens, sind VMs noch besser
Selbstverständlich, wenn du sie
Verbrauchen kannst, wenn du sie
Und zweitens, sind VMs noch besser
Sandboxed, als Container untereinander
Logischerweise, hast ja nicht mehr mal den Host Kernel
Oder irgendwelche Host Ressourcen, die du sharest
Wenn du es nicht explizit weiterleitest
Sondern, es ist ein komplett eigenes System
Was virtualisiert gebooted wird
Cheesy Pro, dankeschön für den Zap
Zum Beispiel, wenn du in einer VM
Genau, genau
VMs brauchen auch
Länger, bis sie gestartet sind
Zwar, wenn das
Eine kleine VM ist, oder auch diese
Das geht schon schnell
Das bootet auch, glaube ich, teilweise gut gemacht
Unter einer Sekunde
Aber trotzdem, ja, das ist
Langsamer, weil ein Container
Ist einfach nur, wir starten einen Prozess
Fertig aus, was anderes ist es nicht
Container muss nicht booten, eine VM muss booten
Container ersetzen niemals VMs
Und VMs werden auch nicht wieder Container ersetzen
Das sind zwei Technologien, die sind beide super
Und beide auf ihre
Starten sinnvoll
Aber laufen Container
Nicht einem eigenen Hostsystem, nein
Ja
Korrekt, das ist so
Deswegen ist das Wort Container ein bisschen
Blöd, weil bei Container denkt man
Denkt man immer an Box und an lightweight VM
Was es nicht ist, Box
In Form von Sendbox trifft es
Aber nicht Container in Form von eigenem System
Ein Container bootet nicht
Ein Container
Startet quasi nur einen Prozess
Im besten Fall
Man kann natürlich einen Script starten, was dann
Weitere Prozesse startet, aber ein Container
Bootet nicht, deswegen probieren wir Systemd
Geschichten in einem Container zu machen, das klappt
Nicht, das geht mit sehr viel Hängen und
Würgen und mit was anderem als Docker
Aber in der Regel funktioniert das nicht
Das ist genauso wie du es schreibst
Du kannst ein Alpine Image in Docker
Verwenden, aber trotzdem benutze den
Kernel vom Host, genauso ist es
Was du von Alpine verwendest
Sind die Libraries, die User Tools
Alle möglichen Sachen, die ganzen
Zusätzlichen Sachen, die zu so einem
Betriebssystem gehören
Die kannst du aus dem Container Image benutzen
Aber der Kernel, der ist vom
Hausbetriebssystem
Und auch manche Ressourcen drum herum sind vom
Hausbetriebssystem, deswegen kannst du auch in einem Container
Nicht einfach sagen, ich lade und
Entlade jetzt Kernel Module, was du
In einer VM machen kannst
In einer VM kannst du
Nur nochmal um das zu verdeutlichen
In einer VM kannst du Kernel Module
Laden und anladen
Ohne, dass du Root bist
Auf deinem Hausbetriebssystem
Also du musst nicht Root sein auf dem
Hausbetriebssystem, wo du die VM startest
Und du hast trotzdem Rootrechte in der VM
Weil es ein komplett eigenes
System ist
Also sofern dir dein
System erlaubt
VMs zu starten
Ja, aber genau so ist es
Das kannst du machen, ja
Also die sinnvollere
Variante wäre wahrscheinlich
Zu gucken
Also nur nochmal so generell, ja
Ob man das in dem Fall tatsächlich nicht
Vielleicht wirklich als Container Workload
Irgendwo laufen lassen kann
Und auf der anderen Seite
Ganz aus ist immer blöd
Skalierung ist schön
Wenn du so eine Grundlast ab kannst
Und halt hochskalieren kannst
Wenn es notwendig wird
Ganz aus ist immer blöd
Weil dann müsste der erste User warten
Und kriegt Timeouts und muss auf Boot warten
Und sonst was in der Richtung
Deswegen kannst du z.B. sagen, ich hab immer
Eine Instanz laufen
Aber wenn es viel User werden kann, ich hochskalieren auf 12 Instanzen
Für welchen Zweck macht man sowas?
Auf was bezieht sich sowas?
Container?
Was interessant ist, ist WebAssembly
Können Motule austauschen?
Da gibt es ein schönes Beispiel
Für
Nervt euch das?
Könnte es sein, dass euch das nervt?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das nervt
Also
Es gibt so ein paar nervige Sachen
Wie z.B.
PC Speaker
Und
Die Holzhammer Methode
Ist
Einfach das Kernel Modul zu
Entladen
Für den PC Speaker
Und dann kann ich noch so viel die Taste drücken
Dann ist weg
Das ist ein Grund, warum man vielleicht Kernel Module
Entladen will
Ist jetzt ein bisschen konstruierter Grund
Aber es ist ein sehr praktischer Grund
Weil ich das selbst ab und zu schon hätte
Gut, das kannst du natürlich vergessen
Also PC Speaker
Ist nicht in Docker Containern
Jaja, das gibt es
Aber das ist meistens keine gute Idee auf Null zu skalieren
Es ist immer gut, wenn du mindestens eine Instanz laufen hast
Dass eben wenn mal einer drauf geht
Der keine Timeouts bekommt
Oder irgendwie aufs Boot warten muss
Oder so was in der Richtung
Deswegen
Ich würde runter skalieren auf 1
Und dann wenn viel ist hoch skalieren nach Möglichkeiten
Was du ja auch machen kannst
Du kannst ja vertikales und horizontales skalieren
Kombinieren
Mit fetteren Nodes
Eventuell
Muss bloß man sich angucken
Ja gut
Kommt auf den Anwendungsfall an
PC Speaker
Das ist aber auch die Holzhammer Methode
Es gibt noch mehr Methoden
Du kannst in deine Input RC
Irgendwelche Terminal Sachen ausschalten
Es gibt ein paar Methoden
Aber wenn du die ultimative Holzhammer Methode haben willst
Um das Gepieper auszuschalten
PC Speaker Kernel Modul anloaden
So
Also
So viel zu dem Thema
Manchmal bringt es einen Container halt nicht zum Test
Das ist das worauf ich raus wollte
Und dann brauchen wir eine VM
Und dann kann man mein Tool hierfür verwenden
Wenn man schnell lokale Test VMs braucht
Da kann man nämlich hingehen und sagen
VM Champ
Run
Und dann zum Beispiel Qt Chat
Bäm
Und was passiert jetzt
Ich habe hier ein 11 Cloud Image runter
Und er startet im Hintergrund eine VM
Und verbindet sich danach
Per SSH drauf
Ich zeige euch das es funktioniert
Ich zeige euch nur nebenbei das es funktioniert
Der hat eine neue VM angelegt
Booted eine neue VM
Und der ist so in
So 20 Sekunden oder so würde ich sagen
Ist er
Fertig ungefähr
Wenn er fertig ist loggt er sich per SSH ein
Und schon habe ich meine VM am Start
Das ist der mir bekannte
Schnellste
Also der mir am schnellsten bekannte Weg
Sich lokal eine Test VM
Hinzustellen
Und ich habe das Tool ja auch gebaut
Weil ich eben öfters den Fall habe
Ich möchte lokale Test VMs haben
Für manche Sachen zum Beispiel
Unit Files
Unit Systemd Unit Files
Irgendwas in der Richtung, irgendwas ausprobieren
Was halt im Container nicht gescheit geht
Sei es beispielsweise auch mal
Per Kommandozeile drauf
Irgendwie
Abinstall hast du nicht gesehen
Was ein Systemd Service hat
Was sich starten lässt
Was halt auch im Container wegen fehlendem Systemd nicht geht
Dann müsstest du eine andere Containerisierungslösung nehmen
Dann lieber einfach eine VM
Willst du Tuner Scale mit Kubernetes kombinieren
Das habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht vor
Ich will es mir erstmal angucken
Hetzner hat
Keine Serverless Funktionalität aktuell
Weder Container Runtimes
Noch Funktions
Noch sonst was
Du kannst dir
Es gibt ein ganz cooles Projekt
Falls du Bock auf Kubernetes hast
Das ist nicht das was ich meine
Es hat zwar viele Sterne, aber das meine ich nicht
Nicht K8, K3S
Das da meine ich
Das installiert ihr in Mini
Einen leichtgewichtigen Kubernetes
Cluster auf Hetzner VMs
Wenn du da Bock drauf hast, kann man sich das geben
Für reinen Container Workload
Ist das
Das ist Nintendo Musik
Du brauchst immer VMs
Denn du brauchst für Kubernetes immer
Wenn du selbst betreiben willst, immer
Einzelnotes und die sind VMs
Zumindest zu 99%
Der Fälle außer lokale
Docker Testnotes
Immer VMs
Wenn du dir einen Google
Kubernetes Cluster kaufst
Sind es auch VMs unten drunter
Wenn du einen Google Autopilot
Kubernetes Cluster kaufst, dann auch
Nur dass du dich nicht selbst darum kümmern musst
Die Frage ist
Was man selbst bauen möchte
Hetzner ist günstig
Du bist
Wahrscheinlich mit Hetzner VMs billiger
Als mit einem Kubernetes Cluster
Beziehungsweise in einer guten Server
Wenn du dir einen
Managed Kubernetes Cluster kaufst
Ich glaube der kleinste
Managed Kubernetes Cluster kostet bei Google Cloud
75 Euro im Monat
Das kostet
Das kostet bei Google Cloud 75 Euro im Monat
Oder sowas
Kannst du Digital Ocean gehen
Da ist es ein bisschen billiger
Aber das
Weiß ich nicht ob das so sinnig ist
Digital Ocean
Ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen günstiger
Kubernetes ist tatsächlich im Vergleich
Zu Google relativ günstig
Da hast du für den Basic Node plus 12 Dollar
Im Monat für den Basic Node
Das ist natürlich unschlagbar
Versus größere
Klauenanbieter
Normale VMs
Sind bei Hetzner günstig
Und die reichen ja auch für alles
Wenn du nichts Großes hast
Was jetzt
So krass vom Skalieren da profitiert
Und sich auch gut kontinuerisieren lässt
Ist eine VM immer noch eine gangbare Lösung
Für 1-2 Services
Die man anbieten muss
Hast du schon mal Midnight Commander benutzt
Ja sicherlich
Aber gehört nicht zu meinem Standard Workflow
So und
Zumindest ihr habt gesehen
Ich hab ne VM erstellt
Lokale Test VM
Direkt per SSH
Connected
Jetzt kann ich noch ein paar weitere Sachen machen
Ich kann mir auflisten lassen
Oh ich hab
Ich hab noch alte VMs
Übrig gebliebene VMs
Vom letzten Mal
Guck mal und wenn man Reste hat
Kann man sogar mit VMChamp clean
Einfach alles aufräumen
Und jetzt ist alles weg
Jetzt mach ich nochmal Run
Da hat man schon gesehen
Neue Status Anzeige hat man gesehen
Man hat
Gesehen dass die IP ab ist
Und pingt
Passt nämlich mal auf
VMChamp
Jetzt seht ihr die neue
Aber
Die hat noch keine IP
Und wenn wir Glück haben
Sehen wir auch schnell
Die IP und dass er noch nicht pingt
Wobei ich kann das ganz einfach simulieren
Überhaupt kein Problem
Ah ne haben wir nicht gesehen
Jetzt ist die VM
Up and Running
Was ich jetzt mal machen kann
Ist dass man sieht mein neuen Output
If Down
Falls das noch funktioniert überhaupt unter Debian
So
Jetzt werdet ihr feststellen
Der hatte mal eine IP
Aber
Irgendwie ist es weg
Also der macht jetzt bei einem List
Auch noch einen Check ob die VM
Lebt dahinter
Warum nicht Watch können wir auch machen
Gucken jetzt hat er
Auch festgestellt oh guck mal das ist
Das ist jetzt neu
Wenn man eine VM löschen will
In der Lokale kann man das so machen
Wohlgemerkt alles mit Autocomplete dabei
Alles mit Shell
Mit Shell Autocomplete hier
Das Lokale VM weg
Ja das ist
Das ist ein neues Feature
Ich bin blöd
Ich hab mein Terminal noch nicht geupdatet
Dass ich einzelne Pains killen kann
So das ist jetzt
Neu Investion 2 dazu gekommen
Dass man ordentliche List Output hat
Minus Minus Local Image
Das geht auch. Hat es jemand gefragt?
Ja du kannst auch
Du kannst auch ein lokales Image verwenden
Das sieht dann so aus
Wenn du lokales Image hast was du starten willst
Kannst du es so machen
Was für IPs bekommen die VMs?
Die vom Default
Default Interface also wenn du ein Default Interface hast
Was KVM eigentlich
Beziehungsweise QEMO standardmäßig anlegt
Dann kriegen die sich hier von IPs
So dann gibt es jetzt noch neu
Die Möglichkeit
Wir starten mal wieder die VM
Achja der casht übrigens auch lokal das Image
Also ihr müsst das nur einmal runterladen
Ein weiteres neues Feature ist
Es gibt jetzt mehr Betriebssysteme
Wir haben jetzt Nebar, Ubuntu und Debian
Zur Auswahl Arch by the way
Fedora 36, Fedora 37
CentOS 7 und
Alma Linux 8 und 9
Haben wir jetzt noch drin
Falls da irgendjemand Bock drauf hat
Und die braucht kann ja sein
Ich persönlich werde wahrscheinlich zum Testen immer bei Debian bleiben
Aber möglich
Gerade Arch Linux ist schonmal nicht schlecht zum Testen
Falls man irgendwelche Packages bauen will
Oder sowas vielleicht
Wobei man das auch im Container machen kann
Mobuntu
Das bringt ja in dem Fall nichts
Ich habe jetzt noch ein bisschen UI
X ist da drauf
Könnte man das einstellen
Das Erstellen der VM
Beschleunigen
Das Erstellen der VM dauert doch nur ein paar Sekunden
Guck mal
Du sagst Run
Und schon ist die VM erstellt
Die VM läuft jetzt
Das einzige was ihr noch ein bisschen braucht
Ist das booten der VM
Und das holen per DHCP
Also da wirst du nicht viel dran machen können
Die VM muss nach wie vor booten
Und sie muss sich per DHCP eine IP holen
Also da kannst du nichts machen
Das ist jetzt auch neu, dass jetzt mehr Images drin sind
Windows Images
Man könnte man theoretisch einbauen
Bringt aber nichts
Weil du dich da nicht per SSH drauf verbinden kannst
So das ist jetzt neu
Das was auch neu ist
Man kann sich jetzt den
Status anzeigen lassen
Wie voll die Festplatte ist
Von der VM
Also verbinden wir uns mal per SSH
Der merkt sich nämlich auch die VMs
Und man kann sich per SSH darauf verbinden
Machen wir sowas mal hier wie
Card Def
Wir machen es wie die coolen Leute
Image Bin von Def Zero
So wir schreiben jetzt die Festplatte voll
Alter
Ich weiß es nicht
So wir schreiben jetzt die Festplatte voll
Und ihr werdet feststellen
MonkaS
Minus Minus Color
Und ihr werdet feststellen
Wir machen jetzt mal Update 0.1
Ihr werdet feststellen
Es wird jetzt auf einmal
Ganz schön voll hier
Also der erkennt
On the fly
Der kriegt jetzt mit wenn eine VM voll läuft
Ist das einmal neu
Danach der Image
Und jetzt löschen wir die VM
Hab ich mich da vielleicht vertan
Kann sein
Oh ja
Ist es
Ja
Auf gehts Pull Request Chat
Da hab ich mich vertan anscheinend
Ja das ist ein Achter Image
So
Also das ist auch neu
Dass er das hier jetzt überwachen kann
Weiteres Neues
Ich muss unbedingt das Killen von Paints
In mein Terminal einbauen
Sonst dreh ich durch
Ich hab's schon eingebaut, aber ich hab die Confi nicht gepusht
Weiteres Neues Feature
Was auch sehr praktisch ist
Man kann jetzt
Zum Beispiel sagen Run für neue VM
Und wenn man jetzt mal guckt
Hier läuft ja noch die Q-Chat VM
Q-Chat 1 läuft ja noch
Mal angenommen ich möchte die jetzt überschreiben
Da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen
Run Q-Chat
Und dann sagt er mir
Moment die VM gibt es doch schon
Willst du die löschen und neu erstellen
Da kann ich sagen
Yep will ich und Enter drücken
Aber wir machen mal nein
Und ich zeige euch noch was anderes was jetzt geht
Was auch ganz praktisch ist
Minus Minus
CMD
Kann man jetzt angeben
Und da kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel noch übergeben
Nachdem die VM aufgebaut ist
Macht doch mal bitte ein Update minus Y
Und danach ein Echo 1
Echo 1
Oder Echo Kekl nach
Root Kek W
TXT
So und jetzt kann man das ausführen
Dann sagt ihr okay Moment was ist da los
Die VM gibt es ja schon
Wir überschreiben die VM
Und jetzt werdet ihr gleich feststellen
Wenn wir uns da verbunden haben per SSH drauf
Bin doch ne Stunde am schwätzen wir haben uns ja nicht mal
TrueNAS angeguckt egal ich hab Zeit
Wenn heute nicht MMO Kreisel grind ist hab ich Zeit
Bis jetzt hat auch keiner was geschrieben im Discord
Hab ich Zeit bis 22 Uhr
Kein Ding
So und wenn die VM dann oben ist
Was ein bisschen dauern kann
Weil er macht jetzt ja ein Update
Und alles möglich im Hintergrund
So und jetzt bin ich drauf
Und jetzt werdet ihr feststellen
Jetzt wurde hier in Root
Eine Datei Kek W angelegt
Das ist das was ich als Custom Command reingestanden hab
Und ich kann auch direkt installen machen
Ohne dass ich Update machen muss
Weil Update wurde schon gemacht
Also man kann jetzt auch zusätzliche Commandos
Ausführen lassen direkt nach dem Startup
Kann man das auch programmieren
Dass der automatisch minus minus
Color übergibt? Ja Moment das hat ja
Mit meinem Programm nichts zu tun du meinst das hier
Das kannst du machen du kannst
Ein Alias anlegen
Also wenn du kein Bock also mal angenommen
Kein Bock jedes mal
Watch minus
0,2 minus minus
Color zu schreiben kannst einfach sagen Alias
Watch gleich
Und sobald du das dann verwendest
Wirst du feststellen
Es funktioniert
Kannst einfach
Ein Alias anlegen
Das ist ein guter Alias
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist ein nicer Alias
Das machen wir doch mal
Tatsächlich
Der erscheint mir ganz praktisch zu sein
Jetzt kannst du es ausführen und das
Funktioniert weiter
So ich glaube
Das war es an neuen Features
Ach ne Moment
Eines der praktischsten Sachen
Hab ich euch ja noch gar nicht gezeigt
So guckt hier ist die VM
Weil das so schnell geht
Weil das so schnell geht steh ich die mal rüber auf den anderen Desktop
Also hier seht ihr die grafische
Terminal Ausgabe
Von der VM
Braucht ihr normalerweise nicht
Aber ich zeig es dir mal da drüber
Ihr könnt jetzt sagen VM Champ
Reboot oder Reset
Je nachdem was ihr wollt oder Restart
Worauf ihr Bock habt
Restart Qt Chat VM
Und bam die VM wird neu gestartet
Das hab ich auch eingebaut
Weil da haben einige danach gefragt
Kann man den Kram nicht irgendwie resetten automatisch
Oder kann man den Kram nicht per Kommandozeile resetten
Wenn er irgendwie gecrashed ist oder abgekackt ist
Ja, so siehts aus
So ich glaube das war es jetzt an neuen Features
Ja das muss ich euch nicht zeigen
Man kann jetzt Minus Minus Cores angeben
Kann ich, komm wir machen einfach
Wir machen einfach eine zweite
Wir machen einfach eine zweite VM
Minus Minus CPU
3 CPU Kerne kann ich da jetzt angeben
Jetzt erstellt er eine VM mit 3
3 CPU Kerne wenn ich das haben will
Das funktioniert
Ansonsten war es das
VM Champ Version 2 am Start seit 2 Stunden
Also wer Bock hat mal auszuprobieren
Kann das gerne machen
Wer irgendwie da
Muße verspürt
Auch wenn es nur was kleines ist wie die Images
Wo ich mich verschrieben hab zu fixen
Kann gerne ein Issue bzw.
einen Pull request aufmachen
Dann merche ich das, dann habt ihr ein bisschen Aktivität
Dann könnt ihr auch ein paar Projekte hier verlinken
Auch wenn das Projekt nicht wirklich
Irgendwie relevant ist
Gut und jetzt guckt hier Endprog
Und jetzt hat er eine VM mit 3 CPU Kerne
Was man auch sieht mit
VM Champ List
Dass das Ding 3 CPU Kerne hat
Und man kann sich nach wie vor
Darauf verbinden
So
Stern, sehr gut, exzellent
Alias
Watch Command
Muss man das machen, warum?
Der ist
Eigentlich schlau genug zu checken
Dass das Kommando was man intern verwendet
Nicht das Kommando ist was man außen definiert
Zumindest ZSR ist schlau genug
Bei anderen Shells
Bin ich mir da nicht so sicher
So und jetzt noch
Ein nicer Touch bei der ganzen Sache
Ich hab jetzt hier 2 VMs erstellt
Bin fertig mit Testen
Und ich will einfach alles
Weggeschmissen haben, alle Images die ich mir runtergeladen habe
Alle VMs, dann sag ich einfach
Clean oder
Hab ich noch einen Alias
Für clean, ich glaube nicht
Äh ne
Gibt es nicht, sag ich einfach VM Champ
Clean, erlöscht alle
Erlöscht 2 VMs, erlöscht Images
Bäm, weg
Und ihr seht alles clean
Und die Images sind auch alle weg
Kannste doch schnell in der VM ausprobieren
Ne, muss ich nicht in der VM ausprobieren
Weil ich
Weil ich schon auf meinem Hostsystem laufen hab
Und es forkbombt sich hier nichts
Anscheinend vielleicht
Vielleicht macht es ZSR anders
Wir können es auch gerne mal
Wir können es auch gerne mal in Bash probieren
Dafür machen wir tatsächlich mal eine VM auf
Weil ich keinen Bock hab
Dass mein Hostsystem abkackt
Was ist denn eigentlich eine forkbomb
Ein Programm was sich
Mehrfach selbst neu startet
Also was nicht neu startet
Selbst aufruft, mehrfach selbst neu aufruft
Du hast dann einen Einstiegspunkt
Der dann wieder sich selbst aufruft
Und dann haste
Ja das ist ein Beispiel für eine forkbomb
Das sollte man übrigens
Mal in der VM ausführen
Wir können es gleich mal in der VM ausführen
Dann zeige ich euch das
Ich kann euch übrigens auch mal kurz erklären
Was das hier eigentlich bedeutet
Ist eigentlich wenn man die Syntax
Die Shell Syntax verstanden habe
Relativ easy
Aber machen wir mal
So jetzt sind wir in der VM
Ich mache hier unten mal CPUauslastung auf
Also als erstes machen wir das mal mit dem Alias
Weil das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen
Dass Bash da Probleme hat
In der Richtung
Also Bash hat damit auch keine Probleme
Sich hier zu forkbomben
So und jetzt kann ich euch mal die
Original forkbomb zeigen
Ach Quatsch
Und ihr werdet feststellen
Die VM ist freezed
Die macht gar nichts mehr
Und mein QEMU braucht einfach 100%
CPUauslastung
Oder 2 CPUkerne
Also mein QEMU ist RIP
Ihr seht übrigens jetzt auch an der Stelle
Das mit dem ping funktioniert
Manchmal pingt es noch
Aber jetzt ist es komplett im Arsch
Abgekackt
Und jetzt können wir übrigens das Reboot Feature verwenden
Das ist ja abgekackt Reboot QChat 2
Und jetzt können wir warten bis es da oben
Vielleicht wenn wir Glück haben
Wieder geht
Wir können ihm auch mal einen Booten zugucken
Ja er bootet
So und jetzt kann ich euch mal nebenbei erklären
Was das ganze macht
Ok ich glaube es ist wieder da
Vom MChamp SSH
Und wir sind wieder da
Ok ich versuche ich mal zu erklären
Was das ganze macht
Und zwar
Wir kopieren das mal in
Wobei in der VM ist ja egal
Also warum das funktioniert
Das ist eine sogenannte Forkbomb
Weil die sich mehrfach immer wieder selbst aufruft
Das hier ist eine Funktionsdefinition
In Bash
In Bash definiert man Funktionen so zum Beispiel
Bloop Bloop
Und das ist eine Funktion
Echow 1
Und wenn ich jetzt Bloop aufrufe macht der immer Echow 1
Sieht man das in der Tabelle wenn die crash
Ja dann wird die IP rot
Dann respondet sie nicht mehr
So also das
Das ist eine Funktionsdefinition in Bash
Man kann das auch irgendwie so machen macht aber keiner
Das heißt was man hier sieht ist eine Funktionsdefinition
In Bash
Und zwar definiert man hier eine Funktion
Die einfach Doppelpunkt heißt
Was bei mir Bloop heißt
Ist in dem Fall eine Doppelpunkt
Doppelpunkt ist der Funktionsname
So und in den Klammern
Ist der Body der Funktion
Also das hier was bei mir Echow 1 ist
Das heißt wir definieren eine Funktion die den Namen Doppelpunkt hat
Und die ruft sich selber Doppelpunkt
Wieder auf
Und nochmal sich selber
Im Hintergrund
Also die ruft sich zweimal
Und packt diesen
Aufgerufenen Prozess in den Hintergrund
Das ist wichtig weil ansonsten wird
Es ja an der Stelle hängen bis es
Beendet ist
Das heißt hier ruft sich das
Zweifach wie oh es geht zumindest schneller so
Hier ruft sich das zweimal auf
Schickt es in den Hintergrund
Und das hier ist einfach nur das Ende der
Funktionsdefinition also ich könnte ich hätte auch
So was machen können werden wird auch funktionieren
Das ist das Ende der Funktionsdefinition
Und der abfließenden Doppelpunkt dient dazu
Das ganze Initial einmal aufzurufen also
Das hier
Ruft die hier definierte Funktion auf
Die ruft sich dann intern zweimal selbst auf
Und schickt sie in den Hintergrund und
Deswegen
Läuft dann alles mögliche voll auf dem
System wo du das ausführst
Von irgendwann
Speicher von Prozess
Tabellen und alles mögliche
Das explodiert komplett und das
System ist nicht mehr benutzbar
Weil du
Versuchst unendlich viele
Funktionen aufzu
Das kann man mit Ulimit
Das kann mit Ulimit
Also
Beschränken
Mit Ulimit kann man angeben was manche
Was manche Prozesse also was neu
Gestartete Prozesse machen dürfen
Und
Was halt nicht
So und man kann zum Beispiel jetzt
Wenn man sagt U
Ulimit
Minus C
Nee Minus U
Ich weiß es gar nicht aus dem Kopf
Ich glaube es ist Minus
Kurz nachgucken
Kannst jetzt zum Beispiel Ulimit
Minus 100
Und dann können wir die Forkbomb aufrufen nochmal
Und wenn wir Glück haben ist das Limit genug
Das es nicht abkackt
Bash Fork Retrial Resource
Temporary Unavailable
Jetzt geht das System nicht kaputt
Weil wir limitiert haben
Wie viele
Prozesse
Da gestartet werden dürfen
Er kackt natürlich auch ein bisschen ab aber
Er läuft ja immer noch
Ja so siehts aus
So und jetzt kommen wir mal
Zu
Trunas
Wird Zeit
1 Stunde 15 geschwätzt
Also wer mal ein Tool ausprobieren
Will kann das machen
Es gibt ein Arch User Repo
Ich sag mal nicht von mir
Meins kommt die Tage erst
Es gibt ein Arch User Repo
Vom Vorti
Das baut, das benutzt nicht das Binary
Das baut selbst aus dem Master
Kann man aber auch da drüber benutzen
Ansonsten
Releases
Und das Binary runterladen
Oder selbst bauen mit
Geht beides
Ups
Den wollte ich jetzt nicht anklicken
Gute
Alles klar
So jetzt gucken wir uns mal
Trunas Scale an
Ich muss jetzt mal erklären
Warum ich mir das überhaupt angucken will
Und zwar Hyper Converged
Storage Scales
Up and Out
Alter welche Business High IQ
Business Menschen haben denn da wieder dran
Open Hyper Convergent
Storage Scales
Up and Out
Was darf man sich da als normal
Sterblicher eigentlich drunter vorstellen
Ja Storage, das ist auch das Einzige
Was ich verstehe, genau, Storage
Gut, mit Open kann man sich
Noch was vorstellen, mit Scale
Irgendwie auch, aber
Das Hyper Convergent
Das ist auch so ein neues
Buzzword
Worauf zu stehen die letzten 1-2 Jahre
Ja, also der Grund
Warum ich mir das angucken will
Ist folgendes
Aktuell habe ich bei mir
Lokal Unraid im Einsatz
Auch wenn ich Unraid lange Trash Talk habe
Habe ich es jetzt mittlerweile doch
Im Einsatz, weil ich es eigentlich
Eine ganz gute Kombination fand
Aus
Ganz gute Web UI
Für
Shares einrichten und sonst was
Die Plugin Funktionalität bzw.
Die App Funktionalität ist ganz nice
Auch wenn das meiste Community angeboten
Ist, aber
Du musst ja um manche Sachen nicht keine Gedanken machen
Du kannst VMS drauf laufen lassen
Du kannst Docker Container mit einem halbwegs hübschen
Face drauf laufen lassen
Ohne dass du dich
Um irgendwelche Docker Compose jammelst oder so
Kümmern musst, das fand ich als Kombination
Für Unraid eigentlich
Ganz
Nice
Wobei ich sagen muss, so richtig 100%
Glücklich bin ich mit Unraid nicht
Die brauchen mir manchmal
Ein bisschen lange Probleme zu fixen
Es gab letztens ein Problem
Wenn ich das Docker Container nicht richtig habe updaten lassen
Haben sie irgendwie zwei Monate gebraucht das zu fixen
Oder ich glaube es ist mittlerweile gefixt
Ja noch mehr
So Dinge, dass zum Beispiel Probleme gibt
Beim Path
Through von USB Geräten
Bei manchen wo du irgendwie Trick 17 machen musst
Da bin ich nicht so 100% glücklich
Mit Unraid
Das könnte
Das könnte noch ein bisschen besser sein
Das geht immer noch nicht, das kann doch nicht sein
Das kann nicht sein, dass sie 2-3 Monate
Für so einen Scheiß brauchen
Das ist un.. wie soll man sagen
Kann man nicht händeln, 2-3 Tage lasse ich mir ja gefallen
Aber bei so essentiellen Sachen
Wie Container updaten
Das muss innerhalb von spätestens eine Woche
Gefixt sein, ist es aber anscheinend nicht
Also wie gesagt
Ich bin nicht so 100% glücklich mit Unraid
Proxmox
Fällt bei mir lokal auch
Ein bisschen flach, weil
Das nicht genau so richtig gut
Meinen Use Case trifft, den ich hier lokal habe
Ich habe eine neben ein paar Raspberry Pi
So ein paar ESPs
Also mein Hauptziel ist natürlich daheim
Dass ich mich nicht großartig drum kümmern will
Ich will ja keinen zweiten Job für meine Infrastruktur daheim
Deswegen habe ich auch kein Kubernetes Cluster
Oder sonst was daheim
Und ich habe so ernsthaft schon mal drüber nachgedacht
Ob ich mir nicht vielleicht wirklich ein fertiges
Nass kaufen soll
Und dass ich mich hier eine wirklich schnelle
Wirklich zackigen HP
Microserver habe mit genug Festplatten drin
Sonst wäre eigentlich rausgeschmissenes Geld
So und
Wie gesagt Proxmox trifft
Meinen lokalen Anwendungszweck auch nicht
100%ig
Das erste ist
Dass kein Docker Support drin ist
Ja du kannst LXT
Und darin Docker und du hast aber ein
Gescheites Webinterface dafür
Es kommt mir nicht mit Portainer, Portainer mag ich persönlich
Gar nicht
Weiß nicht wer das verwendet
Das ist doof, dass da kein
Native Support für gibt
Und das andere ist, Proxmox ist halt eine reine
Virtualisierungslösung
Beziehungsweise LXT
Containerlösung
Ich weiß nicht welches fertige Nass
Ich mir kaufen würde, habe mich ja nicht mit beschäftigt
Also wahrscheinlich irgendein Cyanology
Ding und wahrscheinlich ein 10 Gigabit
Cyanology Ding, weil ich mich mittlerweile
an 10G gewöhnt habe
Und auch hier die Hardware daheim
für den ganzen Kram habe
So, aber
Es ist halt, nennen wir es mal eine
recht reine
Virtualisierungslösung und das ist halt nicht
meine Anforderung
Ich will Netzwerkshares
übers Webinterface zusammenklicken können
außerdem finde ich den
ist 10G schlimmer als
5G, ja doppelt so schlimm
Das wollte ich übrigens gar nicht
anklicken gerade, ich wollte eigentlich das Bild daneben
anklicken, natürlich 10G ist
doppelt so schlimm wie 5G, das ist ja logisch
So, Docker Compose hatte ich
selbst eine ganze Weile lokal
ist
auch nicht so geil
irgendwie, ich war damit
auch nicht glücklich, ich habe ja lange Zeit
auch Android Trash Talk
habe gesagt, installiert euch einfach einen Debian
oder Ubuntu Server lokal
und dann haut ein Docker Compose drauf
drei, vier Services rein und fertig
das zum Beispiel mit meiner
selbst installierten Kiste ist halt das
VM Management dann wieder doof
weil du kein gescheites Webinterface hast
dann musst du dann Remote Wirt Manager und sowas
verwenden, alles, alles irgendwie
unterm Strich nicht
so toll
So, bei
Proxmox kommt noch dazu, warum ich
warum ich da lokal keinen Bock drauf habe
ist, achso, und noch eine charmante
Sache an Android ist ihr Ansatz
mit
RAID
dass es eben kein ZFS ist
sondern
im Prinzip asynchrones
gespiegeltes
Asynchron
gespiegelter Sync, da kannst du halt
dementsprechend unterschiedlich große Platten verwenden
kannst auch deine Platten komplett voll machen
ohne dass es Probleme gibt
dafür hast du halt auch nicht den großen Performance
Vorteil davon
die Kombination aus einem
SSD Cache
und diesem Asynchron
Sync von Android ist eine ganz charmante
Sache für lokale Installationen daheim
für Enterprise Einsatz ist das nichts
aber für daheim ist das durchaus in Ordnung
auch dass man unterschiedlich große Platten verwenden
kann finde ich nicht schlecht
und vom Handling her ist es auch nice
und
doch mittlerweile
haben die auch ZFS glaube ich seit der
neuesten Version oder nach der
oder die nächste Version
hat ZFS Support
ZFS ist auch so ein Ding
das würde ich mir zweimal überlegen
ob man das haben will
ZFS hat sehr coole Features wie zum Beispiel
die eingebaute Verschlüsselung
die sie ja hatten
noch vor FreeBSD und sowas also die
ZFS und Linux Leuten
eingebaute Verschlüsselung
mittlerweile in ZFS
also das war früher
Propitär von Oracle gegeben hat
mittlerweile
gibt es glaube ich auch das
Feature dass man
Pools
erweitern, nicht Pools wie netten
sich das so Rates quasi erweitern kann
dass dieses Feature ist quasi seit 5
Jahren Testing in ZFS und Linux
gut aber
mit ZFS würde ich mir das trotzdem überlegen
weil ZFS bringt tatsächlich
einiges an Komplexität
rein
Snapshots die ganze
ZFS ist eine coole Sache
und ZFS
entgegen der Meinung
des FreeNAS Forum
beziehungsweise des TrueNAS Forum
oder wer auch immer das jetzt heute ist
braucht man bei ZFS auch nicht
3TB RAM
um es im Heimbereich ordentlich
betreiben zu können
da sind ja so Dinge im Umlauf wie
mindestens
was ist das?
RAM pro 10GB
Storage oder irgendwie so
ganz komisch oder 1GB pro
Terabyte oder sowas in der Richtung
das kann man
recht easy mit den heutigen
aktuellen
mit den aktuellen Storage Preisen geht das
noch halbwegs aber trotzdem
stell dir mal vor du hast da 13TB
Platten drin da brauchst du mindestens 30GB RAM
aber wozu im Heimbereich?
und du kannst ZFS ohne Probleme
auch mit weniger RAM
betreiben
dann hast du weniger Caching
logischerweise
und
De-Duplication kannst du vielleicht nicht machen
aber mal ganz vorab sehen das will auch kaum einer
das ist im Heimbereich auch nicht so wild
wenn du da nicht so viel Caching kannst
du kannst ja immer noch eine SSD als Cache verwenden
also ZFS ist auch ganz
gut zu betreiben daheim
trotzdem würde ich es mir tatsächlich überlegen
ob man das im Heimbereich haben will
ja es hat nice Features aber du musst auf einige Dinge achten
du musst zum Beispiel darauf achten
dass du ZFS Pools
oder Volumes, ich bin mir gerade gar nicht
sicher aus dem Kopf wie das heißt
dass du die glaube ich nie
ganz voll machst
weil du sonst Probleme hast
die wieder drauf zuzugreifen
und überhaupt leer zu bekommen
und du solltest auch nicht mehr als 85%
des Speicherplatzes füllen
weil ZFS sonst Probleme hat irgendwie Checksummen zu generieren
also muss man schon auf ein paar Sachen achten
das nächste ist
wo ich mir auch Gedanken machen würde
bei ZFS wenn es mal nicht mehr geht
wenn es mal irgendwie Probleme gibt
das Vergnügen hatte ich schon
also dann wartet mal ab
bis ihr mit einem Rescue System
startet und dann erstmal 15 Minuten
googeln müsst wie man genau überhaupt
jetzt richtig ordentlich in ZFS Pool
mountet
ja das kann man machen
muss man aber auch erst machen
und dann muss man erstmal gucken
wie mountet man den Pool und was ist denn jetzt das Problem
also wenn es nicht geht
hat man dann tatsächlich
ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen
ja schön Leute
wenn ihr es aus dem Kopf wisst
weiß das auch jemand aus dem Kopf
der sich das vor 2 Jahren mal eingerichtet hat
sonst nie was mit ZFS macht
und ihm das nach 2 Jahren kaputt geht
wahrscheinlich nicht
und wenn es mal irgendwie nicht funktioniert
mit dem Import dann wird es eh ganz haarig
die Möglichkeiten zum recovern
sind mit ZFS
auf jeden Fall ein bisschen schwieriger zu benutzen
wenn es mal wirklich kaputt geht
das heißt man muss sich einfach überlegen ob man das wirklich
im
Heimbereich
benutzen möchte
es hat coole Sachen
viele von den coolen Sachen
sind nice to have im Heimbereich
aber
jetzt auch nicht so
so der Gamechanger
Snapshots sind super nice
Geschichte im Heimbereich
auch keine Frage
gerade die Möglichkeit dass man
Snapshots übers Netzwerk an anderen
ZFS Pool schickt und sowas ist schon
nice
Snapshots sind cool
dass du bei ZFS nie das Problem hast
dass deine Festplatten irgendwie Fehler haben
können ohne dass du es
mitbekommst ist auch nice
hat schon ein paar Sachen
im Endeffekt haben will und sich den
Overhead Verwaltungs-Overhead
gönnen
will muss jetzt jeder selbst wissen
deswegen bin ich mit Proxmox als reine
Virtualisierungsplattform und ZFS
bei mir daheim auch nicht so happy
zumal ich halt auch rein
mit einer reinen Virtualisierungsplattform
nicht so groß als ich anfangen kann
also im Prinzip
ich bin weder mit Unraid so richtig glücklich
noch trifft Proxmox so richtig
gut meinen Use Case daheim deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht
gucken wir uns doch einfach mal
TrueNAS Scale an
das ist das was
früher mal
FreeBSD
was früher mal
FreeNAS auf
BSD Basis war
so viel jetzt
jetzt habe ich es
dann laden wir
uns das doch mal runter
wir machen nicht
Nested Virtualisierung in Virtualisierung
wir machen dann später vielleicht Nested Virtualisierung
um das VM Feature zu testen
aber wir machen nicht
Nested Nested Nested Virtualisierung
deswegen lade ich es hier runter
so das ist das was früher mal
FreeNAS war wie gesagt damals noch
auf BSD Basis
und soweit ich weiß ist TrueNAS Scale
mittlerweile
auf Linux
und TrueNAS Core
ist glaube immer noch
BSD
und Enterprise Support
und sowas keine Ahnung aber ich glaube Scale
ist das was wir haben wollen
ok wo gibt es
den Download
äh
wo ist der Download
Leute
ach hier
ha
fast wie bei Ubuntu
früher wo du auch dachtest du musst
ist das mittlerweile
eins besser gemacht die Ubuntu Download
Seite ja Moment Moment
wenn man hier drauf geht und jetzt auf Free Download
klickt
was
ist das
ok
ja die haben das mittlerweile besser gemacht
früher sah es immer so aus als musst du
was spenden an Ubuntu was du überhaupt nicht
musstest
ok
Download
Current Stable
Version
dann laden wir
es nochmal runter
auf gehts
2 minutes left
elementary OS
ja
das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern das haben wir uns im Stream
auch mal angeguckt ich muss sagen
ich fand elementary OS tatsächlich
eines der wenigen auch wenn es
für mich sich nicht gut geeignet hat
als tägliche
zu benutzen Linux Distribution
eine
der wenigen Linux Distros
wenn ich das richtig in meinem Hinterkopf habe
wo ich auch im Stream gesagt habe
das macht irgendwo einen
konsistenten und gut durchdachten
Eindruck gibt es ja nicht so viele Desktop
Distributionen wo man das drüber sagen kann
ich weiß dass du den Download meinst
kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
dass sie sich da auch zum Spenden aufgefordert haben
also es gab ein paar Distros
die fand ich nicht schlecht die würde ich
auch jemand empfehlen der auf irgendwas gut gestyltes setzt
also elementary war eins davon
so 0.8.15
mäßig kann man Linux Mint
sicherlich auch empfehlen was ich
vom Design her und vom
so wie sich
insgesamt
einheitlich anfühlen
was ich auch persönlich nicht schlecht fand
war dieses China-Chinesen Linux
Linux
ich überleg grad wie es heißt
wisst ihr noch wie das heißt?
der ist Deepin
Deepin Linux genau ja
Deepin Linux das fand ich auch ganz cool
aber wie gesagt ich würde kein
China-Chinesen Linux benutzen
wie gesagt ich werde eh nichts anderes verwenden als
irgendwas Arched-Basedes
allein schon weil ich da mein i3
und mit meiner Custom-Config verwenden kann und gut ist
so Truner Scale nice runtergeladen fertig
dann installen wir das mal
New Virtual Machine
Workstation 17 ganz toll
Installer Disk
ich installiere das later
Linux ja sieht gut aus
wie viel Platz habe ich noch auf C?
ok genug zum testen
auf jeden Fall
Truners
Number of Processors
Number of Cores
bisschen scheppe Anzahl
RAM
32G
na komm 16 16G sollte erstmal reichen
16G RAM
NUT
is
Pritched
Pritched Network Warmer
Next Next Next
Create New Disk
wir wollen es nicht splitten
wir machen 200Gb
Lade
Truners VMDK
Customize
so der Printer kommt raus und die Soundkarte kommt raus
USB
CPU und so das sieht alles gut aus
Finish
dann gucken wir doch mal
Truners
CD, Image
Download
auf gehts
schauen wir uns mal an wie das funktioniert
ja ja ich hab finished install
Alter was piepst du rum
Truners Installation
wir skalieren
horizontal
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt Leute ich habe keine Ahnung
von Truners
Macht er standardmäßig GPT und
UEFI statt BIOS? Gute
Frage
ich glaube nicht
wir stellen es mal auf UEFI um
hast du recht
Power off
gucken wir mal wie gut das damit klarkommt
ich glaube der macht standardmäßig immer noch
BIOS Boot
wie rapiepst
vielleicht soll ich
das Ganze nochmal ordentlich machen
nicht free stretch
keep aspect
ratio
ok Installation
wo liegt der Unterschied zwischen UEFI
und BIOS
ich hab keine Ahnung was genau
der Unterschied ist
also ich kann dir nur sagen
dass UEFI die deutlich
neuere Geschichte ist die genau unter anderem
so Sachen wie
Secure Boot
und mehr Devices
und Maus Support und so was
im BIOS kann
aber was jetzt
ganz genau der Unterschied ist zwischen
allem außer dass UEFI
neuer komplexer ist und mehr kann
ich hab keine Ahnung
warum kann man da eine alternative
Baudreit auswählen
vielleicht für den Fall der Fälle dass man das über
Material Port installieren möchte
warum auch immer
man das machen muss
ok Install
Upgrade vor allem 200 GB
Platte
Sekunde Leute
Moment mal das ist ja Blödsinn was ich hier mache
ich will ja Raid Geschichten
testen da müssen
noch mehr Platten rein
so wir machen jetzt
noch ein paar Platten sonst kann ich das ja gar nicht ordentlich
ne Chat
nicht GPT
Chat wir machen das anders
das hier bleibt die System Platte
und
wenn ich installiert hab
hänge ich neue Platten rein
und gucke dann mal was das damit
macht
ja du du
das war mal
wir installieren jetzt erstmal und dann
konfigurieren wir über das Web Interface neue Platten
eh
kleines System ja 200 g
aber mal abgesehen davon das ist ja eh so ein
growing file system
es braucht am ende
nicht viel
Oh Nein
W-was
Web UI Authentification
Method
User oder Root User
Administrative User
ok Leute
Massive Passwort
1,2,3,4,5,6
Best
Ich benutze nur best practice Passwörter
und das sind natürlich die verbreitetsten
ich mein
wie kann ein verbreitetes Passwort schlecht sein
das muss ja schon einen Grund haben warum so viele Leute benutzen
Create a Swap Partition
ja
Ok
Also ich weiß nicht ob trunas für usb stick ausgelegt ist, also unraid ist für usb stick ausgelegt
Soviel weiß ich, die booten auch ins ram vom usb stick
Also ein bisschen hübscheren installer hätten sie auch machen können oder?
Der installer ist äußerst nichtzahnt
Macht der überhaupt noch was?
Das ist aber kein bsd mehr
Da sind wir, Trunas installation on sdr succeeded, please reboot and remove installation media
Ja alles klar, machen wir ein reboot system
Und jetzt müssen wir installation media remove und jetzt rebooten wir nochmal
Ok, trunas scale auf gehts, gib ihm
Ok, sieht furchtbar advanced aus beim booten
Aber sofern er bootet soll mir das recht sein
Ok, also config network haben wir ja
Alles klar, 2.1.2.1, alles klar, dann machen wir das, können wir von der vm aus machen
1.2.1.2.1, 2.1.2.1, zack, ui, admin, 1,2,3,4,5,6, safe
Da sind wir, in unserer trunas kiste
Ok, Leute ich habe trunas eine weile verwendet, ich habe trunas nicht einmal angeguckt, ich habe wirklich keine ahnung davon jetzt
Deswegen müssen wir uns das jetzt zusammen mal anschauen in ruhe
So erstmal dark theme standardmäßig, was ich schon mal sehr nice finde
Status of true command, was ist true command? Ach so, irgendein cloud service von denen
Nee, jetzt nicht, jobs, da sieht man irgendwelche background sachen, alerts, settings
Ich mag das web interface, das web interface gefällt mir, ohne miss gefällt mir jetzt schon
Magst du investieren? Ja, ich habe ein paar stonks, ich habe ETFs, die sind dieses Jahr allerdings nicht gut gelaufen
Ich muss sagen, ich mag das web interface, das gefällt mir, das hat was, das ist ein bisschen material design like
Aber nicht so krass nervig material design like, dass man schon keinen bock mehr drauf hat
Also bis jetzt im ersten Blick gefällt mir das web interface ganz gut
Check for updates
Keine updates, ok, storage, was hat er da? Keine pools, logisch, ich habe ja auch nichts drinne
Create pool
Ja gut, ich habe keine devices, das funktioniert schon mal nicht
Dann hängen wir doch mal ein paar Festplatten rein, mal gucken, wenn ich Festplatten reinhänge, ob der das on the fly checkt oder nicht
Hard disk hinzufügen, jawoll
Create new disk, ja machen wir mal 16G, oder 32G, wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben jetzt
Moment, das ist die falsche VM
Ja, ich habe es auch gerade am Namen gesehen, dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt
Ok, also hängen wir es mal hinzu, disk
Create new disk
32G
Single file, trunas, perfekt, so noch eine, noch eine
Network, network, network, single file, 32G
Weiter, weiter, ok, nice, dann schauen wir mal, ob der die jetzt auch automatisch erkennt oder ob man rebooten muss oder sowas
Das System hat 200G, nee so viel werde ich davon auch nicht verwenden
So, hat der Platten erkannt, der hat keine Platten erkannt, das heißt man muss jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal sagen
Neue disks detecten please
Ich glaube nicht, dass man dafür restarten muss
Das Problem ist nur, ich weiß nicht, wo der Knopf ist
Zum neu detecten von angeschlossenen Festplatten
Muss man wirklich rebooten, wenn man neue Festplatten angeschlossen hat?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass man da rebooten muss
Ok
Trunas detect disk
Adding disks
Auto scan for new hard disks
Im Terminal?
Show up in storage, ok, das ist ja viel, hier storage hat man, ok, da ist es ja nicht drinne
Ja, könnte sein, dass es daran liegt, dass ich in der VM bin
Aber ruhig mal, wie komme ich irgendwie auf ein Terminal hier drauf?
Das wäre auch noch mal interessant, aha, shell?
Ah, excellent, excellent
BF, was haben wir denn da alles am Start?
FDisk, FDisk kann man da drauf, BLKID, wir haben ja gar keine Ahnung
FDisk kann man da drauf, BLKID, wir haben ja gar nichts drauf
Sudo minus I vielleicht
Ok, aber BLK, aber BLKID minus T, ach nee, ah Gott, wie funktioniert das?
SDA, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, der hat die schon erkannt, nee, Moment, das ist alles SDA
Wie ging das BLKID 3? Nee, LSBLK, LSBLK, ah das habe ich gesucht
Ok, nee, der hat noch nichts erkannt an Disks, was aber auch klar ist, die sind ja nicht formatiert
Nee, sieht nicht so aus, als hätte er irgendwelche, irgendwelche neu eingesteckten Disks erkannt
Also, dann Reboot, wobei Reboot, ups, wir Rebooten mal über das Webinterface, müsst ihr lernen, wie das funktioniert
Dashboard, System Settings, Boot, vielleicht
Da, ah, ok, finde ich gut, halbwegs selbsterklärende Webinterface, schonmal ganz nice
So, jetzt Reboot da, ah guck mal, der hat auch im Hintergrund so eine Schleife laufen, gucken ob es wieder da ist, das ist eine gute Idee
Also ich muss sagen, das Webinterface gefällt mir, das macht jetzt einen etwas moderneren Eindruck als das von Unraid zum Beispiel
Wobei das auch noch geht, Proxmox habe ich zu wenig Erfahrung, um da was zu sagen
Sieht echt poggers aus, ja Moment, wir haben ja noch gar nichts gemacht, wir haben uns so das Webinterface angeguckt
Die Optik sollte einer nicht täuschen
So, alles klar, wir haben 5 Cores und laufen auf einem i7 13900K
Ja, so halb, gut, die VM denkt das halt
Ok, Dashboard, was kann man hier, kann man Zeug konfigurieren, etwa Gadgets
Spannend ist das jetzt nicht
Gibt es Dashboard Plugins oder sowas?
Ok, jetzt erstellen wir mal, ok, hier sieht man Netzwerkinterfaces, ist ganz hübsch gemacht, was haben die Grafen gemacht?
Chart.js, ok, also Netzwerkinterfaces, blub blub, Storage, gucken wir mal, Create Pool
Da haben wir doch schon was
Was? Sollte es nicht normal sein, dass die...
Achso
Hä?
Ach, vielleicht haben die unter der Haube die gleiche Serie nochmal
Moment, SDA und SCC, Moment, warum ist SDA jetzt auf einmal die...
Hast die geklonen?
Ich hab die einfach hinzugehängt, wir gucken mal was passiert
Mal gucken, wir gucken einfach mal was passiert
SDA, Moment, läuft mein System jetzt auf SDB oder was?
Ja, mein System läuft auf SDB, das ist natürlich ganz toll
Die sind virtuell, ja, aber ich hätte mal erwartet, dass sie zumindest die Serie nochmal... Egal, wir machen das jetzt trotzdem
SDA und SDB, was wollen wir machen?
Suggest Layout, ok, was sagt der mir da?
Stripe, ja gut, gibt ja nur zwei zur Auswahl mit zwei Devices
Vielleicht sollten wir doch drei Devices reinhängen
Weil du kannst ja im Prinzip nur mirrorn oder stripen mit zwei Disks, was willst du großartig machen?
Also entweder kannst du beide Disks quasi zusammenfassen und den einen Inhalt spiegeln auf den anderen für Auswahlsicherheit
Oder du kannst beide zusammenfassen und die Daten splitten zwischen beiden für mehr Speed
Also quasi, quasi, Rate 0 vs. Rate 1
Wir schalten noch mal kurz aus
Und ich hänge nochmal eine dritte Platte rein, weil ansonsten ist das Ganze relativ unsinnig auszuprobieren
Add Disk
32G
Jawoll, ok, noch mal starten
So, schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt wieder an Start kommt
Ja, Waiting
Du hast dir ein Cyanology-Naske gekauft, schau her, was?
Doch, ist eine gute Sache, ich finde die Dinger gar nicht übel
Alles was ich bisher gesehen habe davon, kann man durchaus machen, wenn man sich möglichst wenig damit beschäftigen will
Und Preis-Leistung passen und man mit den Features klarkommt, ist doch, ist doch alles gut, kann man kaufen
Moment, ich habe nicht nur hier Tabs, nicht nur hier Tabs, ich habe auch noch da Tabs
Und wie hier habe ich ja kaum Tabs, das geht aber nicht, hier habe ich noch ein paar
Aber da muss schon noch ein bisschen was gehen
Medieninformatiker, da müsste es aber zumindest auch schon mal Netzwerk-Storage irgendwie aufgesetzt haben, oder?
Paperless, kann ich nichts zu sagen
Ich habe lokal jetzt auch nicht so super viel Zeug, ich glaube ich habe irgendwie um 10 Container laufen, irgendwie ein Wiki, ein Sammelding für meine Hardware-Teile
Boah, ich weiß aus dem Kopf gar nicht alles
Was aber auch dafür spricht, dass es ja unauffällig und eigentlich gut läuft
Ja, ich habe ein Video gemacht, aber da ist nicht alles drin und das Video ist auch outdated
Und manche Sachen davon benutze ich auch gar nicht mehr
So, also lass mal weiter gucken, jetzt können wir mal einen Storage-Pool anlegen, Create-Pool
Was haben wir zur Auswahl?
So, A, ist das ein B oder ein D? Das ist ein B, dann adden wir das mal hinzu
Zack, also jetzt haben wir zur Auswahl, muss man das hier anklicken? Ja, wahrscheinlich
Raid, Z-Raid, Mirror, Stripe, okay wir machen ein Z-Raid logischerweise, sonst wäre ja blödsinnig
Und jetzt brauchen wir Name, Cute-Pool
Encryption, ja das probieren wir auch mal aus, das ist ja ein neues Feature, neu, gibt es ein paar Jahre schon
Neues Feature, Encryption ist used for user, for user storing in the pool, does not apply to the storage pool or disk in the, hä?
Ach so, dass man aber
Ja, probieren wir das mal aus mit Encryption
Und jetzt?
Okay, also er schätzt 60 Gigabyte, sorry, Gibi-Byte
60 Gibi-Byte, Gibi-Byte sind es nicht Gibi-Byte, Gibi-Byte
Strip, Strip, Strip, Strip, Strip, Strip, Strip
Weil wir haben dreimal 32G, und davon fällt eine weg, weil es quasi so ein Raid-5 ist
Z, Z-FSS-Raid, ist quasi so was wie ein Raid-5
So, Create, guck mal nochmal, Warning, Will be erased, ja alles gut, mach
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du
Was ist Z-FSS-Raid... Hm, was?
Oh, Passphrase.
Moment, ich konnte überhaupt keine Passphrase eingeben, warum nicht?
Download Encryption Key
Achtung Leute, Key League!
Monkeys, Key League!
Ich hätte es gerne tatsächlich in dem Fall sogar mit Passwort oder irgendwas anderem gelockt, dass ich es anlocken muss beim Reboot.
Weil...
Wie... wie anlocke ich es jetzt?
Testen wir mal Reboot, mal gucken, ob er sich jetzt automatisch mountet nach dem Reboot. Das würde mich jetzt...
Würde mich wundern, aber mal gucken.
Aber ich meine, wenn er den Key unencrypted bei sich gespeichert hat, kannst du es doch auch gleich sparen mit dem verschlüsseln, oder?
Ja...
Muss ich jetzt beim Boot vielleicht ein Passwort eingeben?
Nö.
Genau Pass. Muss ich nicht.
Na gut.
Ja, ich habe es jetzt.
Ich habe es jetzt.
Storage. Ja super, das ist gemountet. Ja, aber...
Wo ist denn der Sinn vom Verschlüsseln, wenn das gemountet ist?
Der Key muss ja dann da irgendwie unverschlüsselt auf der Platte oder so liegen.
Was man kann beim Pool anlegen, verschiedene Sachen auswählen.
Was man kann beim Pool anlegen, verschiedene Sachen auswählen. Echt, wo? Hab ich nicht gesehen. Können wir jetzt nochmal ausprobieren.
Okay, wie löscht man den Pool wieder? Hier. Export, Disconnect.
Destroy Data on this Pool. Was? Quatsch.
Was macht Destroy Data? Überschreibt das das dann, oder?
Confirm.
Schauen wir mal. Legen wir den Pool nochmal neu an.
Oh je.
Es hängt. Okay, es hat funktioniert. Close.
Create Pool. Jetzt aber.
Wo? Man kann hier was auswählen.
This disk is part...
Ja, ja. Hab ich. Hab ich. Alles back up. Alles back up. Alles gut back up. Ja, ja. Alles back up.
Rechts vom Namen dann bei Encryption.
Nö, hier kann man keine Passwörter auswählen. Wo kann man hier Passwörter auswählen?
Indeed Application wollen wir auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich seh hier nix.
Also Chat, ich seht ihr hier irgendwie was zum Passwort angeben?
Also ich net.
Also anscheinend doch nachträglich. Okay.
Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Ich download den Encryption Key wieder.
Okay.
Und jetzt? Wo? Manage. Manage Disks. Manage Devices.
Was haben wir hier?
Ah, da kann man sowas einstellen wie Spin.
Also ob die Platten sich ausschalten sollen im Standby und sowas. Okay.
Gut. Gut, dass es das gibt.
Manage Devices. Was haben wir da zu bieten?
Extend.
Da kann man doch nur gleichgroße beziehungsweise minimumgroße.
Ja.
Okay.
Extend.
Da kann man doch nur gleichgroße beziehungsweise mindestens mindestens genausogroße dabeihängen.
Hardware Disk Encryption Drive Info.
Nö.
But Datasets vielleicht gucken.
Encryption.
Es ist unlo... Ah. Edit.
Hier kann man das umstellen.
Hier kann man das umstellen. Achtung. Massive Passphrase, Leute.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Kommt in die...
Nooo.
Okay. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
PBKDF2 Iteration.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was es ist. Ich vermute mal wie oft der Key quasi...
Tja, wie soll man das beschreiben?
Wie oft der Key gehashed wird, bevor das, was rauskommt, dann zum entschlüsseln benutzt wird.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Ja, ist sowas in der Richtung. Okay.
Ist dafür um Brute Force Sachen langsamer zu machen.
Confirm.
Save.
Invalid.
Contains the system data set.
Was?
System? Mein System ist da nicht drauf?
Mein System ist ja da gar nicht drauf.
Was ist denn extra...
Wie man hier auch sieht, dass da gar nichts drauf ist.
Ach, es ist ein System.
Das ist ein System.
Ach so, this data set is used by the system.
Und das bedeutet jetzt was?
Was, was, was, was bedeutet das jetzt genau?
This data set is used by the system.
Use system data set.
What?
Syslog?
Sys...
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Erst unmounten. Okay, ja, why not?
Export.
Confirm export.
Wir deleten mal nicht die Configuration.
Aber wir können die Configuration...
Nee, wir deleten nicht die Configuration.
Ja, heute ist Poggers Modtag.
Leute, jetzt wo ihr alle da seid, während der Pool löscht,
können wir einmal in den Chat für unsere Mods,
die sich immer sehr viel Mühe geben
und auch sehr viel Mist sich durchlesen müssen,
eine Runde alle einmal in den Chat, bitte.
Modcheck.
Für unsere Pog Modges.
Komm, da geht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Gib den Mods mal eine Runde Modcheck.
Vorti, ich hab mir übrigens vorher auch einen Repo angelegt.
Muss ich noch befüllen. Minus bin.
Pogcheck.
Nicht Modcheck, Pogcheck.
Nice.
Sehr schön, Leute. Modges freuen sich hoffentlich.
Mehr kriegen sie ja hier nicht.
Besten Modges.
Okay, no pools. Kann ich den Kram jetzt...
Das geht aber nicht.
Also mit unmounten und so ist hier schon mal nix.
Weil jetzt hier passt Storage und so gar nix drin steht.
Okay, das ist doof.
Darkseid, danke schon für den Sub.
Hast du schon was mit Octopus, die...
Ich hab das schon mal gehört, aber es sagt,
ne, hab ich nix mitgemacht.
Pool. Cute Pool.
Also das funktioniert schon mal nicht, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
So, System.
Was will der...
Was will der hier mit System Pool die ganze Zeit?
Snapshot kann man hier drüber machen? Okay, ja.
Advanced.
Use... Was? Okay, das muss ich mal hier...
Was ist das System Dataset?
Das ist nicht... Das ist anscheinend nicht die Bootplatte.
Jetzt ist er gelockt.
Ne, da ist nix gelockt. Der ist unlocked, oder?
Ach, jetzt ist er locked.
Unlock.
Ja, Choose File.
Was?
Äh, Choose File zum unlocken.
Aber...
Was ich jetzt nicht checke ist, der hat sich das doch gemerkt
und konnte beim Rebooten selbst, dass sich...
Na gut.
Choose File. Das will ich ja so nicht, wenn ich mir dann ein Passwort...
Ähm...
Wo ist es denn?
Pool.
Ach, hier kann man das...
Hier kann man das auch reinpasten.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Save.
Das ist aber so ganz gut gemacht mit dem Keyfile.
Was ich mich frage ist, warum er es unlocken kann beim Rebooten.
Aber jetzt, beim Neumounten, muss ich es einmal...
Einhängen.
Komisch. Na gut.
Fetching Encryption Summary. Ja, dann fetche mal...
Fetch mal hinne.
Was fetcht der denn da?
Und was macht er da eigentlich so lang?
Hab ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht?
Ich meine, ich habe nichts gemacht, aber...
Das dauert mir verdächtig lange, ehrlich gesagt.
Geben wir nochmal drauf, hier auf der anderen Seite, Datasets.
Immer noch locked.
Ja.
Wir gucken mal erst recht, wir schauen mal eine Runde.
MD Rate? Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich für System.
Boot Pool?
Okay, das ist mir way too high IQ, was da abgeht.
Disk Failure?
Aber SDC ist doch...
Ich kann da gar keinen Disk Failure haben.
SDC, SDC1...
Interessiert ja auch nicht, Qtpool ist ja SDC2.
Oder, oder...
Swap? Swap ist SDC...
Ähm...
Also, wenn solche Basicsachen wie Einhängen und Aushängen nicht funktionieren...
Okay, das könnte an meinem VM Setup liegen.
Man weiß ja nie.
Durchaus möglich, dass es an meinem VM Setup liegt.
Aber sollte eigentlich nicht, oder?
Komm, wir rebooten mal, bam.
Okay, also, das ist eigentlich ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen...
Okay, oder?
Komm, wir rebooten mal, bam.
Wir rebooten mal, kann ja nicht schaden.
Guck mal mal, was er macht hier.
Naja.
20 Minuten!
Der will es aber wissen, oder?
Wenn er 20 Minuten braucht, um irgendwas zu booten, dann stimmt doch was nicht.
Okay, er ist wieder da.
Admin, yep, login, login.
Da sind wir wieder, Storage.
Datasets lockt.
Ja, mal gucken, ob ich es jetzt anlocken kann.
Wahrscheinlich wieder nicht.
Wir machen mal ein neues Tab auf, was nicht funktioniert.
Wir machen mal ein neues Tab auf, was nicht funktioniert, okay.
Wir machen ein neues Tab auf, Shell.
Und schauen mal, ob da irgendwas...
Bis jetzt noch alles okay.
Hat das mit dem O2 Code geklappt?
Den habe ich nicht verwendet.
Ich habe mich neu angemeldet.
Unlock child encrypted roots, was?
Also unlock any encrypted...
Machen wir mal weg.
Okay.
Downloads.
Shieldpool.
Add data sets.
Save.
Yes.
Jetzt hat es funktioniert, okay.
Okay, das ging jetzt.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Mit Reboot, mit Reboot hat alles funktioniert.
Ich möchte allerdings trotzdem...
Die Encryption umstellen.
Aber die Encryption darf ich nicht umstellen.
Weil System das irgendwie verwendet.
Also die Logik...
Habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Hä?
Was ist das denn?
Okay, jetzt funktioniert aus...
Gründen.
Alles.
Okay.
Okay, wie lockere ich das wieder?
Ich muss wahrscheinlich...
Ich muss es wahrscheinlich...
Exportieren.
Ich den noch nicht.
Okay.
Ich delete auch mal alles.
Confirm Disconnect.
Und jetzt importieren wir mal, okay.
Import Pool.
Jawoll.
Import.
Und jetzt muss ich ja eigentlich ein Passwort eingeben, oder?
Wobei, an der Stelle muss ich noch kein Passwort eingeben.
Postchamp.
An der Stelle muss ich noch kein Passwort eingeben, sondern ich muss hier beim Unlocken...
Unlock.
Passprays.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Save.
Continue.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert das aus irgendwelchen Gründen viel einfacher.
Du hast das Gefühl, es ist nicht der einzige Weg zum Locken.
Hier kann man auch noch Locken drücken.
Lock.
Bam.
Jetzt auch wieder gelockt.
Unlock.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Bam.
Wieder da.
Continue.
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal ganz gut.
So die Basics mit Locken und Unlocken vom Pool, alles gut, alles nice.
Ich muss sagen, das Webinterface finde ich ganz gut.
Das ist ein bisschen Material Design, aber nicht so abartig Material Design.
So.
Wenn ich das mit ZFS noch richtig Erinnerung habe, dann ist ein Dataset quasi...
Ein Ordner ist ein falsches Wort, so was wie ein Ordner.
Ich glaube, ein Ordner kann man das ganz gut beschreiben.
Also wo man dann wieder weit, wo man ein bisschen schöner unterteilen kann.
Im Prinzip so was wie ein Ordner.
Und ein Z-Wall ist eine Image-Datei, die ich mounten kann, wenn ich das noch richtig in
Erinnerung habe.
Also es gibt zwei Sachen.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel eine VM habe, die direkt auf mein ZFS-Pool gehen soll, dann
kann ich das mit einem Z voll machen.
Und hier kann man es mit einem Ordner quasi irgendwie besser gruppieren.
Aber wir lassen mal das Standard.
Und weil wir können mal add Dataset.
Macht Jonas VM?
Ja, doch, das probieren wir aus.
Also dann machen wir jetzt hier einfach mal, sagen wir, ich habe hier ein ZFS-Pool.
Dann machen wir einfach mal, sagen wir hier, wirkt, nenne ich jetzt einfach mal.
Encryption.
Case sensitive.
Case sensitive ist cringe.
Na doch, lassen wir.
Share time.
Generic.
Samba.
Samba share will ich da nicht mal.
Advanced options.
Read only.
Check some.
Die Duplication machen wir bestimmt nicht an.
Das brauche Ram as fuck.
Snapshot directory.
Copies.
Records.
Okay, was?
Speichern.
So, was haben wir für unsere VMs?
Haben wir einen eigenen Ordner.
Jetzt machen wir noch einen eigenen Ordner.
Den nennen wir jetzt einfach mal share.
Und der kriegt Standard Zeug.
Der kriegt share time Samba.
Gucken, was dann passiert.
Please wait.
Wahrscheinlich macht er Samba an jetzt.
Kann ich da jetzt schon drauf zugreifen mit Windows an der Stelle?
Ich meine, ich habe ja weder, ich habe ja weder User noch sonst was angelegt.
Nee.
Nee, Moment.
Warte mal.
Äh.
Wie?
Äh, ich muss ja Backslash machen, das ist ja Windows.
Nee, geht natürlich noch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil der Samba Service noch nicht läuft.
Okay.
Das heißt, das ist einfach nur, dass der intern sich merkt.
Okay, das wird man ein Samba Share.
Also ein Windows, beziehungsweise Windows, Windows Laufwerk.
Na gut, dann machen wir doch erst mal die simplen Sachen.
Windows Share.
Stop.
Also wir adden ein Windows Share.
Path, Mount, Cute Pool, Share.
Korrekt.
Purpose.
Basic Time Machine Share.
Multi-User Time Machine.
Multi-Protokoll-Share.
Privates.
SMB Dataset and Shares.
Private ist wahrscheinlich mit Passwort.
Und das hier ist public.
Wir machen default Share Parameter und gut ist.
Description Enables.
Safe.
Enable the Service.
Ja, dass der Samba startet, standardmäßig.
Ist gut.
Okay.
Jetzt probieren wir aus.
Backslash, Backslash.
Eins, zwei, drei, eins.
Nein, nein, nein.
Eins, zwei, eins.
Okay.
Admin.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Nein.
Das ist anscheinend kein standardmäßig freigegebener User.
Okay, also muss ich wahrscheinlich noch User definieren vorher.
Nee, Admin hat nicht eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
Admin hat nur eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Okay, User sind.
Kann man den auch einfach public machen ohne User?
Share.
Advanced Settings vielleicht.
Access.
Allow Guest Access.
Okay, allen Rest habe ich keinen Plan von Samba, aber Allow Guest Access klingt schon
mal gut.
Aha.
Can't wait.
Moment, darauf habe ich ja auch keinen.
Moment, ich muss auf Share Slash.
Nee, passt doch eigentlich.
Das liegt nicht an Windows in dem Fall.
Das ist garantiert irgendein ACL.
Ah, da muss jetzt auch.
Okay, da musste aber viel von Hand machen.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es notwendig ist, unter Linux das so zu machen.
Ich habe auch schon Samba was von Hand installiert, aber es ist blöd, dass es nicht irgendwie
ein bisschen per Assistent und es unnötig kompliziert, oder?
Owner.
Jetzt muss ich noch einstellen, wie Guest gemapped wird, oder wie?
Build in Users, gibt es keine Guest Group?
Gibt es keine?
Schau nochmal unter Erweitern.
Ja, kann ich gleich machen.
Access Group.
Everyone.
Das sieht gut aus.
Allow.
Full Control.
Nee, das wollen wir wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Und wie apply ich das jetzt?
Wollte ich use Preset?
Wo ist der Apply Knopf?
Ich finde ihn nicht.
Was macht das?
Ja, meinetwegen.
Okay.
Wofür ist das gut?
This actually removes all RCL from the kernel and any direct hits.
Okay.
ACE has errors.
Jetzt hat es keine Errors mehr und jetzt funktioniert es.
Hä?
Alles gut, was auch immer.
Ah, jetzt darf ich, jetzt darf ich.
Keckl.
Nice.
New.
Warum finde ich immer so komische Bugs?
Null.
Okay, jetzt haben wir Files da drauf erstellt.
Nice.
Okay, es ist deutlich komplexer, hier NAS Funktionalität zu konfigurieren.
Aber das liegt auch am ZFS unten drunter.
Und weil es dir halt auch die ganzen, die ganzen Options bietet als dreimal klicken in Unrate,
ist Vor- und Nachteil zugleich.
Wenn man das alles korrekt einstellen will ganz genau, ist es natürlich von Vorteil.
So.
Gut, gefällt mir trotzdem ganz gut bisher.
Gefällt mir trotzdem ganz gut.
So, jetzt probieren wir mal eine Sache noch aus.
Wir machen jetzt mal einen Snapshot davon.
Weil das ist eines der wirklich coolen Features von, von ZFS.
Wir machen jetzt noch mal einen Snapshot von.
Create Snapshot.
Wobei vorher kopieren wir mal ein bisschen was drauf, würde ich sagen, oder?
Dass wir das auch mal ausprobieren können, dass wir noch ein bisschen was zu tun haben.
Aber ein bisschen, ein bisschen was größeres, was ich da drauf kopieren kann.
Documents.
Battlefield, Battlefield-Files.
Ist nicht so viel.
Ja.
2 GIG.
Ja, okay, nice.
Gib ihm.
Ach, man kann hier gar nicht mehr schließen jetzt.
Probieren wir mal ein bisschen Battlefield drauf.
Ja, 2 GIG, Battlefield, da sind viele kleine Dateien auch.
Ich mein, hey, brauchen wir jetzt nicht, weil die Platten, das liegt eh alles bei mir lokal.
Also das ist jetzt nicht aussagekräftig, was die Performance angeht.
Zumal es auch in der VM ist, bei mir lokal.
Also das muss ja überhaupt nicht übers Netzwerk drüber.
Also nicht übers richtige Netzwerk.
So.
Gut.
Da ist es.
Alle Files da.
Gut, jetzt erstellen wir mal einen Snapshot.
Create Snapshot.
Manual.
Name.
Pogu.
Nee, wobei, komm, scheiße.
Wir lassen mal den standen.
Hallo?
Darf ich nicht mehr rückgängig mal?
Manual.
Naming Schema.
Ah, das ist gut.
Aber man kann auch automatische Snapshots im Hintergrund machen, das ist nice.
Set Include Child Datasets.
Nö, hat keine Child Datasets.
Save.
Okay, wir haben Snapshot gemacht.
Was heißt, wenn ich jetzt zufälligerweise RM minus RF mache, hier in diesem Verzeichnis.
So.
Delete 4 Items.
Und dann auch noch ohne ECC RAM.
Oh nein.
Ja, dann ist im Forum vorbei.
Dann ist, dann ist durch, wenn du das da postest, dass du es ohne, gar ohne ECC RAM machst.
Und auch nicht mit einem Gigabyte pro Terabyte.
Dann ist eh, dann ist eh durch.
Dann kriegst du offiziell die Lizenz zum TrueNAS verwenden aberkannt.
Die machen eine neue Lizenz für dich.
GPL.
Lizenz für dich.
Excluded.
So nice.
Das ist dann quasi die Not So Nice GPL Edition.
Gut.
So, also ich hab jetzt aus Versehen was gelöscht.
Und jetzt restoren wir den Snapshot mal wieder und gucken, ob das wieder da ist.
Also.
Create Snapshots.
Wunderbar.
Manage Snapshots.
Bis jetzt mag ich das UI.
Rollback.
Hold.
Hold bedeutet, dass er die bei automatischem Rotaten nicht löscht.
Okay.
Clone to new data set.
Das ist natürlich auch cool, wenn ich beispielsweise aus einem Backup nur einzelne Dateien restoren
will.
Das finde ich gut, dass es die Option anbietet.
Du kannst beispielsweise das Ding in einen neuen Ordner quasi restoren, dir drei, vier
Dateien davon rausholen und dann wieder wegschmeißen.
Oder wieder.
Du musst es nicht komplett rollbacken und im Zweifelsfall halt auch neue Dateien wieder
löschen.
So, machen wir mal rollback.
In dem Fall rollback.
Also use Snapshot.
Blablabla.
Okay, wenn ich irgendwas neueres drinne, dann mag er nicht.
Okay.
No safety check.
Wir machen confirm.
Rollback.
Data set rolled back to Snapshot.
Go to storage.
Okay.
Warum auch immer.
Und ist jetzt die Daten wieder da?
Die Daten sind wieder da.
Das ist doch cool, oder?
Das ist natürlich, das ist auch was Cooles für ein, beispielsweise für ein NAS in einer
kleineren Firma oder so, wenn sich die Sekretärin irgendeine Mailware per E-Mail eingefangen
hat.
So, und jetzt noch ein anderes Beispiel mal angenommen.
Wir hätten jetzt neuere, machen wir nochmal ein Beispiel.
Machen wir nochmal ein Beispiel.
So, ich hab jetzt neuere Daten hier drauf.
Oder sagen wir mal so, ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt.
Moment, warum ist es leer?
Eben was?
Aber Moment, Battlefield.
So, ich hab jetzt neuere Daten hier drauf.
Ich hab jetzt, in Kekl hab ich beispielsweise ein neues Dokument angelegt.
Plopp.
So, und jetzt hab ich aus Versehen mein Battlefield-Ordner wieder.
War da nicht mehr drinne im Battlefield-Ordner vorher?
Nur mal so, nur mal auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Nee.
Okay, safe.
Moment, stieb der das jetzt in Papierkorb?
Muss ich das jetzt in Papierkorb erst löschen, dass es weg ist?
Sekunde.
Recycle bin.
Nee, ist gleich weg.
Gut.
So, jetzt ist das leer.
So, jetzt gibt's natürlich ein Problem.
Ich kann jetzt, ich kann jetzt den Snapshot nicht zurückrollen, weil wenn ich den Snapshot
zurückrolle, dann ist ja meine Plopp TXT weg.
Mal gucken, ob er das feststellt.
Datasets.
Share.
Ich muss sagen, sehr eingängiges Web-Interface gefällt mir bisher.
Manage Snapshots.
Merkt er das, wenn ich ihm jetzt sage, rollback?
Stop on rollback to safety if at any rate intermediate child.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob eine einzelne Datei zählt, die neue.
Probieren wir es mal aus.
Rollback.
Nein.
Das hat nichts.
Die Datei ist wieder weg.
Okay, das merkt er an der Stelle nicht.
Aber ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, also das heißt, wahrscheinlich ist so zu
restoren eh ne blöde Idee.
Wahrscheinlich ist es deutlich besser zu sagen, clone to new data set.
Ja, das nennen wir jetzt mal so.
Go to data sets.
Und jetzt share ich dieses neue data set auch nochmal als share.
Add.
Mount.
Cute pool.
Share manual.
Ja, alles gut.
Save.
Wenn du meinst.
Nee, Moment.
Moment, mount.
Ich hab.
Ich wollte.
Wait a minute, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Okay.
So, pass.
Uh oh, ich hatte eine Anwesenden label.
Okay.
Was will der von mir?
School of Six 7 9.
Cool!
Wow!
It's like a bit.
Okay.
Nice.
Hey!
This is nice.
Nice.
You did very well.
Good.
Bravo!
Spr
The data said that the clone was ah
Das ist ach jetzt verstehe ich jetzt verstehe ich jetzt könnte ich den löschen weil das
ja quasi der parent von meinem snapshot restore ist okay aber will ich ja gar nicht will
ich glaube ich will den restore löschen enter cute chats zum löschen okay konfirm
error falls es best dependent clones use air to destroy oh no das ist wahrscheinlich
weil ich es weil ich es eben promoted habe delete ja und wie mache ich das jetzt never
geht nie wieder weg für immer für immer ist es da
achte jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich den anderen promoten okay man kann immer nur eins was
oben ist okay das das leuchtet das leuchtet ein jetzt kann ich jetzt kann ich jetzt kann
ich löschen achten pass mal auf jetzt jetzt kann ich löschen nice okay das ergibt irgendwie
sind das finde ich sehr nice schon mal ich mag sachen die in sich geschlossen irgendwie
logisch sind ich muss sagen die verwaltung von netzwerk shares ist irgendwie noch nachvollziehbar
ist aber eine ganze ecke komplexer als beispielsweise jetzt bei unrate ist aber nicht schlecht also
ist ist gut und schlecht vielleicht gleichzeitig man kann mehr machen ist vielleicht ein bisschen
komplizierter auf der anderen seite du machst ja einmal ein preset mit deinen berechtigungen
stellst es ein und du machst ja auch nicht jeden tag fünf neue shares also ich glaube
dass ich glaube das ist ganz okay so was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten also stelle es haben
wir sonst probiert data set also ich probiere gleich auch das ganze vrm zeug und doch gar
krempel aus data protection resilver priority ach ja das müssen wir auch ausbilden was ist
denn wenn eine disk fehlt was ist was ist bei einem disk fail disk fail achtung hier hart disk 32
g settings löschen wir doch einfach mal eine ja remove bäm disk fail mal gucken mal gucken
ob er das merkt der sollte man jetzt hier irgendwas schreiben alert no alerts
gebated gibt es nicht storage wie das ist kein alert wert es ist kein alert wert das
gerade meine festplatte verreckt ist okay wahrscheinlich muss ich es konfigurieren
aber also ich hätte gedacht dass fail fail an disk standardmäßig mit mit dabei ist und ich
wüsste auch nicht wie ich konfigurieren soll ehrlich gesagt es ist nicht critical wenn der
gut der pool geht noch pull ist die krähtet oh no
es muss den nicht okay jetzt will ich den pool jetzt will ich den noch geht er ach jetzt habe
ich einen alarm aha das hat nur ein bisschen gedauert okay vrdisk ist faulted rip disk
gut ja dann muss ich den pool jetzt irgendwie austauschen würde ich sagen also neue 78
arrows okay die platte ist weg also hängen wir eine neue platte rein moment falsche vm
eine neue platte rein hat disk create new virtual disk 32g bla bla bla ja das ist natürlich doof
wenn er das jetzt nicht erkennt dass ich die dran gehängt habe wenn ich jetzt rebooten muss dafür
das ist natürlich blöd dass er die nicht auch das liegt aber an der vm dass er die nicht automatisch
erkennt eindeutig okay wo würde ich das jetzt hinzufügen storage managed devices
online was passiert dann unavailable ja
natürlich sehr gut ja nun gut wie replace replace member disk sdr
replace disk ist not clean was alter force die platte ist weg
warum ist sda jetzt wieder da
ich bin ich bin verwirrt legt es legt es an meinem vm kram hat er das hat er das die die klar
kann es sein dass er die 2 3 dass er die gleiche einfach wieder erstellt hat kann es sein dass
er die die gleiche wieder erstellt hat das ist durchaus möglich ja ja da hat die gleiche wieder
erstellt guck mal 3 1 nee zwar doch doch doch doch doch doch 1 3 4 1 2 3 ja ja da hat die wieder
erstellt ok also noch mal removing eine platte jetzt hat er jetzt hat er wieder festgestellt
dass die graded ist hoffe ich mal ja faulted faulted ok und jetzt und jetzt fügen wir fügen wir
noch mal eine neue platte hinzu weil das war der hat das alte image reused und das ding hat gedacht
ah die platte ist wieder da ist ja logisch so also add new disk die anders benennen müssen wir
aufpassen dass das funktioniert next next next create new ding single file 32 gig so heißt nicht
vier sondern heißt 69 die gibt es auf jeden fall noch nicht ok alles klar faulted gut was
passiert denn bei extent new disk achso da kann man alle durch ersetzen also faulted replace
member das
kann ich die nicht ersetzen ach moment die habe ich vorher durch sich selbst ersetzt ach so war
das der hat die neue auch wieder als sda erkannt na gut dass das hot swap funktioniert jetzt nicht
weil er erkennt nicht dass meine disk dran gehängt wurde gut das heißt ich muss jetzt
rebooten was was ich wahrscheinlich bei einem echten system höchstwahrscheinlich zumindest
nicht machen müsste immer blöd noch den pool besonders zu belasten wenn eine disk kaputt ist
deswegen ist es auch komplett also rate 5 ist eben bisschen fragwürdig wenn die platten besonders
groß sind und wenn man dann auch noch viele platten drin hat dann ist rate 5 eigentlich ja
nur eine frage der zeit bis es komplett kaputt ist
wieder da nein es ist nicht wieder da
muss mehrere anschlüsse definieren ohne platte wie anschlüsse ohne platte wie wie
soll ich anschlüsse ohne platte definieren verstehe ich gucken wir mal gleich aber ich
glaube nicht dass darüber den restock und das storage gab es in discs gibt es kein gibt es
kein rescan so die sani da sind ok jetzt hat er das erkannt die sdb ist die neue sdb ist die
neue also kann ich jetzt sagen add to pool nee ich will wahrscheinlich nicht sagen add to pool
sondern ich vermute mal moment das liegt daran lockt ich muss es erst anlocken 1 2 3 4 5 6
die macht iq password continue close storage die graded ja unavailable alles klar replace
replace mit dieser disc alles klar replace disc geht eigentlich relativ easy muss man sagen
problematisch wird es nur wenn es mal nicht funktioniert und dann von hand du irgendwie
zfs tools ran muss ich muss sagen ihr wisst ich bin immer schwer zu begeistern aber ich finde
es echt gut gemacht zfs ist keine easy geschichte auch jedes interface gefällt mir bis jetzt ganz
gut wir gucken wie es mit container und vms aussieht aber das macht doch echt einen guten
durchdachten managen sparen benutzbaren eindruck also bis jetzt bin ich echt positiv überrascht
was ich von den wenigsten system in der richtung war ja ob media volt hat mir gar nicht gefallen
proxmox für mein heimeinsatzgebiet nicht selbst andere hatten wir am anfang nicht gut gefallen
das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht das handling von den shares hier ist ok man kann
sogar nfs und web darf shares anlegen war noch eins ganz cool wenn man web darf share cute pool share
ich will unbedingt mein battlefield ordner sharen per web darf lul weh change
achso ne das geht nicht
ok schenken nur mal nummer kackel user berechtigung
web darf starten proxmox auch in dark mode nice ok wie ist die web darf adresse davon
jetzt woher weiß man das jetzt was hat ein web darf für ein port überhaupt
der htp ist ja schon belegt bis ui true nas web darf port das sieht man bestimmt
passt das sieht man noch bestimmt bei services oder services wo sieht man hier services services
da ok port 80 80 80 80 admin 123456 achso na shit man ja das geht dafür muss man jetzt wirklich
ein user anlegen oder ok aber man sieht schon mal dass es prinzipiell funktioniert oder ich
oder ich könnte vielleicht 80 80 slash share oder wie habe ich wie habe ich das genannt
lul weh na nee da standen passwort wirklich wo wo
wo habe ich das eben beim anlegen übersehen ach beim port ach bei den bei den system setting
stand das daftest ok nice daftest ach ach user ja daftest daftest nee shit ja was ist
das was ist das default passwort default user admin eww nee was ich schenne o
der user vielleicht web darf der user wäre gut zu wissen leute basic authentication ja aber ich
brauche doch den user dafür es wird keins genannt ja als ich die user leer lassen
nö geht auch nicht dann weiß ich es nicht dann keine ahnung dann löschen wir den share jetzt
einfach wieder weil will ich eh nicht verwenden gut so wir haben stemshots ausprobieren wir haben
das replays raus gut alles nice dann gucken wir uns mal die virtualisierungs achso ja moment
moment gleich supporten wir auch virtualisierung dauert kurz einmal rebooten dazu was ist unter
apps ich denke mal so was wie vorkonfigurierte docker images oder sowas cpu virtualisieren von
intel vtx das braucht man damit nested virtualisierung funktioniert also leute erwartet jetzt keine
performance wunder aber ein rechner ist stark genug also es ist schon ganz brauchbar selbst mit
nested virtualisierung kann man kann man durchaus benutzen und der apps ist kubernetes stellt das
bezweifle ich dass da kubernetes was du mit oder kann man die als kubernetes notes verwenden was
echt total zweck zweck zweck entfremdung wir nested funktioniert ohne probleme guck
zack nested virtualisierung vm ist erstellt wo sie sich jetzt bei dhcp eine ip bootet und schon
ist man ratzfatz auf einer neu erstellten nested virtualisierten vm drauf auch gut ist auch
minimales debian und außer ist das hlogin macht da nix achso gui lasse ich ja da drüber
auch nicht laufen habe ich habe ich nicht vor cockshot bm sind wir auf der vm so also da kommen
wir mal unter apps choose a pool for apps ganze pool warum kein data set für apps wahrscheinlich
macht ein eigener failed to mount data set kanada ex fell to my operation not permitted ok nice
gg moment was kubernetes stellt
ich habe mich anlockt ich habe ja neu gestartet dann diliten wir das mal wieder ich hoffe die
application sind dann auch encrypted alles andere wäre nämlich echt doof so hier an lock
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 bm bestes password ever close apps cool choose die haben da echt
not kubernetes für drunter die idee ernsthaft leute die idee ist nicht doof wisst ihr warum
die nicht doof ist weil die einfach irgendwelche helm charts nehmen nehmen können und die und
deswegen haben die das bestimmt auch so gemacht die haben einfach irgendwelche buttons im web
interface unter der haube macht es einen helm macht es einen helm install also die idee ist
gar nicht mal schlecht ich hoffe es warum sind die applications unencrypted das ist doch
scheiße kann man das wenigstens einschalten im nachhinein encryption
ob es stash als app gibt ist stash nicht das bitbucket bitbucket
als atlasien bitbucket vorgänger
lasst uns das
doch ist es so richtig was ich sag dass ist das was das bitbucket server ist ok apps
ja not found settings choose pull onset pull launch ach man kann auch direkt
docker image starten finde ich auch schon mal cool ok view catalog was soll ich suchen stash
gibt es nicht aber es gibt bestimmt so ekliges zeug wie nextcloud und so was was ich nicht
haben will das alles
und nicht so viel
doch haub assistant ist drinne also es wäre tatsächlich was wobei ich ganz ehrlich haub
assistant nicht im kubernetes laufen lassen würde ich finde kubernetes ist eines der dinger die
sich richtig gut nach vm sind und nicht und nicht hier drin gibt noch ein community chart ok
true nas community chart zeigt mal her true charts catalog und das fügt man das jetzt
einfach so hinzu mannatsch kettler das ist gut gemacht das ist wirklich gut durchdacht
das gefällt mir ja nervt mich catalog namen ja
und utility so was die tori prefers train stable ja meinetwegen branche main ja was
ist hier main oder master master vor lasst es mal nicht twitter hören mal anzeige ist raus
safe refresh available applications nope
hallo
die tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut der cyk
high iq sync action. du brauchst punk git? ich denke nicht. achso
wait a minute. talking expired. alles gut. wo ist mein... ok ich muss wahrscheinlich
nicht wirklich punk git machen. add catalog. punk shit. master. ich vermute mal, dass ich
master machen muss, oder? so ein how to add gibt es da anscheinend nicht. save. community
catalog. wie ist tuna scale? also ich muss sagen, ich finde das web interface und das
handling vom store, das hat durchaus was. das gefällt mir bis jetzt ganz gut. das gefällt
mir bis jetzt ganz gut. sag mal bin ich so blöd das irgendwie zu adden? wie funktioniert
das? funktioniert doch nicht, oder? true charts. also ich wusste irgendwie, dass es helm charts
sind. docs getting started. introduction. könnt ihr mir nicht einfach sagen, was ich adden muss?
intro. ja aber woher weiß man das? aber woher weiß man das, dass man das machen muss? wo
steht denn das? wo steht wie das funktioniert? ok man muss es anscheinend wissen.
also was muss ich adden? catalog. das da. das da muss ich adden. ok also noch einmal.
manage catalogs. warum machen die nicht auf ihre webseite so eine bam, das einfach hinzufügen
erstmal, dann weißt du Bescheid. add catalogs. community repository. und ist das jetzt main oder
master? das ist main. ok gut. save. jobs. gib ihm. hinzufügen please. catalog create.
habe ich jetzt das richtige hinzugefügt. bei punkt 4. make sure you can reach. aha. da.
enterprise and stable. ok es singt immer noch. available applications. aber ist das schon ein
bisschen mehr? ist das schon ein bisschen mehr geworden? nee nicht wirklich oder?
aber jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren. aber jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
das letzte mal wäre er da schon abgebrochen.
der wird wieder failen und ein falsches repo. warum? ich habe doch jetzt genau das richtige rein. ich
habe doch das jetzt reinkopiert. das müsste jetzt das richtige sein. das ist genau das was
hier drinne steht. du hast aber punkt git angegeben. das sollte eigentlich keinen
Unterschied machen. geht doch. geht doch. ok noch sind keine available applications drin.
aber es scheint schon mal ein bisschen mehr zu machen jetzt. aha. fertig gesüngt. nice.
available applications. ein bisschen was drin. ok so mal. was soll ich gucken? stash? hat
irgendjemand geschrieben stash? das brauchen wir alles leute. wichtig. ganz wichtig. da war
ja klar dass der chat irgendwie so komische dinge vorschlägt wieder. true lulwe. das brauchen wir
jetzt nicht. es gibt ernsthaft ein porn organizer? warum kann man das nicht organisieren wie alles
andere auch? also warum braucht es dafür etwas spezielles an software? ok testen wir einfach
mal was. hauen wir mal das da drauf. nur zum ausprobieren. ich will da nichts großen. ich
will nämlich noch die virtualisierung testen. healthy bla bla bla bla. ok. und wie installiere
ich jetzt was? ach so indem ich auf install klicke. lul hätte ich jetzt auch drauf kommen können.
dachte das ist irgendwie in dem popup drin. application inversion. ok das ist die neueste.
ist das ist das schon die? moment. 1.19? was? wait a minute. 1.19 really?
ach das sind die helm chart version. richtig du hast recht. ja dann weiß ich ja gar nicht welche
das im endeffekt unten drunter installiert. desired replicas. jetzt immer ernsthaft macht
es irgendwie sinn? also kann man das? man kann auch theoretisch sogar mehrere kubernetes notes
damit wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwie machen. aber das werden die wahrscheinlich nicht übers
web interface supporten. wobei ich dann auch was anderes als tunas nehmen würde dafür. ok time
zone ist berlin. europe ist eigentlich scheißegal zum ausprobieren. admin credentials. admin 123456
password. cackel at kappa 0.com. run production mode. load host list. load ip. expose ports.
load balancer? haben die da metal lb oder sowas dabei? dass es mit local ips funktioniert?
die haben tatsächlich metal lb drauf. ok port 10.037 ssh service. brauche ich eigentlich
gar nicht. kann ich den ausschalten? ich will den ssh port gar nicht exposen. pvc storage. alles klar. ok
ich installiere jetzt einfach mal. die haben ingress dabei. ok leute da kommste aber als noob
nicht weiter wenn du nicht ein bisschen kubernetes erfahrung hast. welchen ingress verwenden die?
wahrscheinlich hauen die mir da noch irgendwie einen engine x oder sowas drauf. aber wenn ich
einen ingress verwende dann bräuchte ich eigentlich keinen load balancer. aber mal ohne. ok das ist
richtig. moment ich glaube dieses chart ist nicht customized für trunas sondern generell
das ist einfach das zeigt einfach alle dinge an die das kubernetes helm chart hergibt. das
heißt das muss jetzt hier drauf gar nicht mal großartig funktionieren. ok dann ist es vielleicht
doch nicht so sinnig hier. aber was gut ist man kann docker container darin starten. ich habe die
documentation gecheckt. wir probieren mal. moment cute app. wo ist die cute app? die installieren
wir jetzt. docker container wird jetzt hinzugefügt. releases. die cute app. gut dass wir die letztens
erstellt haben aber nicht releases. wo gehe ich denn hin? packages. cute app wird insane. alles klar. ok
ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich dieses feature benutzen werde. launch docker image.
core ist glaube ich noch free nass. application name. cute app. was will er von mir? version?
welche version bezieht sich das hier oben jetzt? die docker version oder? oder was soll das sein?
wir lassen einfach mal alles die vorn. ok port forwarding. container port 80. node port 8811.
9 0 1 0. gucken wir mal ob jetzt die cute app gleich funktioniert. storage. volumes. brauche
braucht das alles nicht. ok das ist schon eine gewisse komplexität. bluefin. was ist bluefin?
only paid. ok wo ist unsere cute app? install application. da ist es.
schauen wir mal. 9000. was habe ich gesagt? 9010. das ist ziemlich kompliziert das handling muss
ich sagen. also https. ne wobei da gibt es eigentlich keinen sinn. müsste keine https sein.
ja ne. anscheinend. kann man sich jetzt logs angucken? logs? das heißt dann exchart. das
container. was will der mit excharts? was will der von mir? das war noch deploying?
ist immer noch am deploying. also das image ist public. also der kann jetzt. sollte das
nicht so lange brauchen. aber mein token ist mal wieder abgelaufen. ok. nice. deploying. tja
und woher weiß ich jetzt ob es irgendwie hängt? fail to pull image. ok. aber das funktioniert.
aber das geht. du hast keinen latest tag. ich habe ihm aber gesagt, dass er latest benutzen
soll. ach moment habe ich das vielleicht nur unter einer version und gar nicht nochmal
unter latest gepusht. ok dann liegt das an mir. ja ok ok. machen wir nochmal? machen wir nochmal?
kein ding? ah auf terminate. cute app. launch docker. ich weiß nicht was er mir mit dieser
version sagen will. so. latest tag. den da. bitte schön. so. und den rest lassen wir so. save. ach fuck
ich habe die ports vergessen. shit. ok aber zumindest das download sollte jetzt funktionieren. ja hat
aber. ah jetzt active. edit. ports. port forwarding. add container port 80, node port 90, 10. save. ok
jetzt aber. 12112.121.9010. cute chat. ah ja ja. ok ja. also handling mit docker container ist nice.
ich muss sagen die das helm chat handling und das alles ja da weiß ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht
ob mir das so gut gefällt ich weiß wir können ja mal was was einfaches installieren ja wie heißt
dieses dieses eine wiki was so beliebt ist bei den ganzen self-hosted leuten
bit. ne. ne. book stack. das gibt's gibt's doku wiki auch das ist auch easy ok
das ist ja immer ein doku wiki weil da kann es nicht kann nicht viel schief gehen
ah ja
admin 123456 pull name doku wiki doku wiki email at kappa allul.com doku wiki name hatten wir doch
grad schon enable pvp configuration was load balancer expose ports ja ok
main service ports
ingress
moment das ist das ok das hat ein ingress dabei da müsste ich jetzt dns namen drüber
ding sonst will ich ja nicht. versteht ihr was von ports? ich bin verwirrt. das wird
wahrscheinlich ohne ingress so nicht gehen ok wir installieren es einfach mal. wir installieren
es jetzt einfach mal und gucken ob es ob dann irgendwas irgendwas ist auf dem port und dann
installieren wir noch eine debian vm. debian image download. wir laden uns schon mal eine
debian image runter. official image image stable release yo yo gap her. debian net install jawoll
wir installieren es jetzt wir installieren nicht das minimal image will wissen ob das alles
hat es jetzt funktioniert? deploying immer noch. successfully successfully successfully
finde ich nice umso mehr successfully umso besser aber es ist immer noch deploying wahrscheinlich
weil der load balancer nicht funktioniert. der load balancer funktioniert nicht weil wir nicht
in der cloud umgebung sind und kein metal lb haben also das wundert mich jetzt ok das ist
das ist von der handhabung her tatsächlich nicht so nicht so nice ja muss man muss man muss
man wirklich was sagen aber mit dem port geht es er steht allerdings weiter auf deploying ach jetzt
steht es auf active die haben den metal lb dabei anscheinend oder? das muss ich jetzt mal kurz das
muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz checken sudo inus i kubectl ah ne. das ist doch natürlich dass
kein kubectl dabei ist. muss ich jetzt einrichten dass ich mich auf den cluster connecte ach so
ah ok get ports minus minus all namespaces metal lb sage ich doch habe ich doch richtig predicted
ein prometheuse operator dass man sogar metriken abfragen kann
es ist möglich dass es in k3s integriert ist ich habe k3s noch nie ernsthaft mir
angeschaut könnte man vielleicht dauer machen sehr schick also die idee dahinter da kubane das
drunter zu verwenden finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht die auch die anzeige mit dem port
finde ich ok ja also das hat was das sammelt bei mir pluspunkte das hat wirklich was das gefällt
mir das haben die nämlich so gemacht dass man sich relativ wenig gedanken um den kubane das shit
unten drunter machen muss die sache ist plus die wenn mal wirklich was nicht läuft und du
übers webinterface nicht weiter kommst dann bist du doch komplett aufgeschmissen als jemand der sich
nicht im detail bisher mit kubane das beschäftigt hat also ob das so eine gute idee ist weiß nicht
ich finde ich finde den ansatz sinnvoll weil so kann man auf die 30 milliarden helmschatz
zurückgreifen die es halt gibt man hat starke imitiert also doch er kommt aus falls kann man
anscheinend nicht ins importieren sehe ich jetzt hier nirgendswo ssh kann man höchstwahrscheinlich
enable standardmäßig nicht enable kann man machen autostart port 22 wahrscheinlich das
das funktioniert ssh 12 12 2 b 2. es endet nicht als max als atmen ich habe noch offen anzögern
ok leute hat aber kein sinnvolles password ok da muss man wahrscheinlich Lives hinterlegen
für ssh server wenn ich jetzt wüsste wie man keys hinterlegt egal gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an
kriegt man bestimmt raus ich will mir nämlich auch das virtualisierungs feature angucken
wenn es nicht wirklich gerettet wenn der ssh server geht dann muss man sich immer noch muss
man immer noch durchblicken wie man im zweifelsfall irgendwelche gefailten kubernetes
helm deployments fix es gab dort die option mit admin with password ja aber admin darf
sich nicht einloggen und oder wo hier bei ssh oder wo ach so ok chat ist es gut dass
ihr dabei seid weil manchmal fällt mir sowas gar nicht auf zahle hierfür schmerzen ssh login
ja ja ja ist ja gut da sind wir und jetzt dürfen wir so gut jetzt dürfen wir gut werden
ja geht potts ctl man kann auch minus a machen da bist du lost wenn du dich damit noch nie
beschäftigt hast jemanden damit noch nie beschäftigt weiß nicht mal dass man sich
was anzeigen lassen kann also das ist auf jeden fall was was auf den ersten blick easy und
praktisch aussieht aber dann wenn was nicht geht hast du probleme und sehr gut du kriegst
zumindest immer deine daten raus hoffe ich hoffe ich df-h ja gut das ist halt zfs und docker
zfs mit docker images das sieht halt so aus da ist halt vorbei da blickst du immer durch
ja volume secret doku wiki volumes alles klar wo hängt das
ja ja ja ja ok volums wie komm ich jetzt
alter alter also releases cute ab 2
gut die haben keine volume ich lege mal kurz im doku wiki was an und create das page bla bla bla
ganz toll ja super haben wir eine seite im doku wiki cd doku wiki wie komme ich da jetzt auf die
falls ich da irgendwas von hand fixen ok hier liegt nichts drin haben die keine volumes liegt
das alles intern in irgendeinem import oder so und dass man weiß er gibt eigentlich auch keinen
sinn so dass es hier sind keine daten drin dann ist die frage wo das wo die daten von den
da ist die frage wo die daten von dem ganzen zeug liegen also wir haben releases doku wiki
ab und hier haben wir noch hier haben wir noch die die volumes ok ja da muss man sich auf jeden
fall auch ein bisschen gedanken machen zum storage wo man den krempel hinhaut weil im
zweifelsfall kommste nimmer dran pages hier start das ist meine seite das ist natürlich
ein bisschen komplizierter durchzublicken ok und was ich auch ein bisschen doof finde ist
dass das nicht standardmäßig encrypted ist das kann man aber bestimmt nachträglich einschalten
gehe ich mal von aus gut jetzt installieren wir noch mal eine vm nämlich auch ein feature was
ich das gefällt mir aber bis jetzt tatsächlich ganz gut es ist deutlich komplexer als das
android handling ja wir haben nur wir haben nicht so viel ich beende mal kurz meine das
brauche halt brauche halt ram so add virtual machine gest operating system linux demian heißt
das jetzt so glock local jep glock start und boot vnc bind ok next finde ich ganz gut gemacht
wobei ich persönlich mag ja interfaces in der mitte weil was ist der sinn davon dass ich hier
die hälfte des fensters nicht benutze ja ist ja auch ist auch irgendwie unsinnig wo aus zwei das
ein bisschen schneller geht custom memory 512 reicht voll und ganz next disks 10g ist auch ok
hier in wird kommt es rein adapter type ich will bestimmt nicht die wird da ja auch kann
meck attach tunic ok das wird ein es wird eine bridge sein an der das dran hängt alles wow alter
ok next installation mit upload installer image jup choose file
download debian net install das ist alles nice gemacht also ich muss wirklich doch komm
an warum kann so die so dinger nicht nicht funktionieren ach so ich hab die safe location
gar nicht ja ich habe für isos kein extra wird speicherstens wird ja ok er ist jetzt
war storages data sets wir legen jetzt mal ein neues für an vielleicht data set
aus der name hier iso isos
kucken ob das jetzt ob das jetzt funktioniert virtualisierung
virtual machines jetzt muss ich die ganze missnummer einstellen debian
next alles gut passt next fall hier wird next
next hoffentlich geht das jetzt upload images to things ob isos choose file präge leute präge
oh man corner hast du recht ja das finde ich ist auch ein großer vorteil ok upload ist auch als
admin nicht so ohne weiteres möglich wahrscheinlich weil mir irgendwelche rechte fehlen heißt im
endeffekt wir machen das jetzt mal einfach easy mode wir gehen jetzt hier hin in unseren share
der aus ich habe an dem share nichts geändert warum ist der share auf einmal nur noch per admin
lesbar acl sind kaputt warum gehen einfach acl random kaputt das ist schon mal ziemlicher
ziemlicher crap ich habe web darf nur den ordner unterschrieben zumindest war das mein ziel
isos was wir jetzt machen debian image download
weget outdated overrated debated damit hätte nicht gerechnet es hat so ein paar kleinigkeiten
immer wo man sich fragt warum ist das jetzt passiert aber das kann durchaus auch an meiner an meiner
bedienung liegen isos da ist doch ein debian install next height vom msr alles klar weil
ich sofort aber ja genau mein vga adapter will ich da unbedingt passt run ok safe please geh
halt einfach autostart stoppt start ok display was jetzt erlaub pop-ups er ist ja gut richtig
ab ok install funktioniert doch ganz gut
little memory alle du hast 512 mb jetzt jetzt machen wir hier nicht machen wir hier nicht
auge
für nested virtualisierung geht das doch voll klar kann man sich nicht beschweren die frage
ist ob es ins internet kommt ob das netzwerk technisch funktioniert dann wird mich interessieren welche
ip hat sich gezwungen hat es gepridged noch mal hat es gibt es sehen wir gleich
1 2 3 4 5 6 bestes bestes root password aller zeiten max user 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 immer
die einfach nur die best practice best passwörter aller zeiten ja der cp kann aber auch sein dass
es sich gezogen hat von irgendein internen flitsch und nicht von meinem von meinem mikrotik router
kann ich ich könnte jetzt im dhcp nachgucken aber ich gucke einfach gleich auf dem system dann
also leute für nested virtualisierung flutscht es doch eigentlich ganz gut oder kann man auch
nicht sagen hat trunas eine firewall weiß ich ob man da bestimmte sachen blocken kann aber
die beste variante dürfte doch sein einfach nur ports und services einzuschalten die man braucht
also ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht also ich sehe keine und ich wüsste auch nicht genau na doch man
könnte vielleicht man könnte vielleicht netze netze blocken von wo es kommt also sieht nicht so aus
netwerk vielleicht ja tatsächlich interfaces steady crowds ok guck mal man kann sogar man
kann sich sogar als open vpn client irgendwo dran hängen immer so schlecht
sieht nicht aus als hat es irgendwie firewall funktionalität läuft auf trunas auf
ein pay gibt es tunas für arm no nein läuft nicht connect scanning installation mehr was
germany irgendwie hat er sich beim reconnect ein bisschen mein bisschen den den irgendwie
das terminal kaputt gemacht beim reconnect gerade oder wenn ich refresh machen oder sowas
disconnect reconnect jetzt ist broken hat dieses web vnc nicht irgendwie was zum bildschirm
refreshen es sieht jetzt ein bisschen kaputt aus no vms haben aber gerade in scale einen
komischen bug sagt das ist der komische design des design des die vms können netzwerk technisch
nicht auf alles zugreifen was innerhalb von scale läuft hat mich bei meiner hau ja das liegt
wahrscheinlich daran weil das über mcve tab geht und da kannst du nicht auf sachen im haus
zugreifen da müsstest du eine extra bridge einrichten genau ja das ist normal das ist
kein design decision das ist also das ist eine eine limitierung von diesem netzwerk treiber
den die verwenden ich weiß ja nicht so genau was das hier gerade macht aber wir können
die dürften nicht die dürften nicht mehr die müssten direkt eine bridge einrichten sonst
funktioniert das nicht ja bsd hat es anders gelöst ja ja übrigens das ist so kaputt
es liegt nur daran weil ich mich irgendwie disconnected habe eben mit vnc das ist jetzt
ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen jetzt
deswegen ist cool wenn man gerade wenn man netzwerk karten hat die virtualisierung unterstützt dann
hast du das problem nicht die haben ja quasi intern dann noch mal verbindungen eingebaut
ja das immer wenn man mcve tab verwendet da kannst du aufs netzwerk zugreifen aber
nicht auf den gleichen host
selection ist complete nice requesting reboot nein keine install wie hänge ich jetzt das
moment jetzt muss ich ja das iso wieder aushängen das ist ja nice das ist doof dass das iso
drin geblieben ist boot local gibt es auch so was wie boot einfach weiter lokal booten
wie hänge ich das iso wieder aus jetzt wird es die weißes disk cd rom details
also löschen wird es jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein oder
edit einfach löschen ich kann es löschen aber das müsste man muss es doch aushängen
können dann spätestens auch bei usb das ist echt blöd ok naja das vm handling ist
nicht so geil das gefällt mir nicht wobei es nicht so ein großer unterschied ist zu
zu unrate da ist es auch nicht so so der wahnsinn wie weißes cd rom wie kommt man
wieder zurück nur hier drüber fehlt der button ein jetzt proxmox into moment booted jetzt
nicht mehr seriously der booted nicht mehr wenn ich das cd rom weil die weil die settings
jetzt im arsch sind oder was oh come on das ist doch müll das oh nee also das sind so
basic dinger die sollten eigentlich funktionieren von den der muss eine ordentliche xml generieren
dass das funktioniert jetzt stimmt die bootreihenfolge nicht und er ist abgekackt oder die installation
hat nicht funktioniert das kann natürlich auch sein ja ne device manager die weißes
moment die installation hat nicht funktioniert die installation aber die installation war
doch fertig da doch gesagt ist abgeschlossen oder nicht oder habe ich mir irgendwie was ja
doch ich habe ja sogar reboot nach installation ok da stimmt mit den settings noch irgendwas nicht
sie doof also nicht geht deswegen hat er auch das auch der grund warum er das überhaupt
gebootet hat von von disk noch mal hättest du nicht nehmen sollen das ist die fall setting
der erwarte ich dass das 2023 geht bei mir lokal funktioniert es ja auch als geht das
ausschalten nicht weil ich keinen ku emu agent ab und es gibt kein force power oder auf gibt
die weißes cd ok hier kann ich wenigstens das ist noch nicht so rot also das vm handling ist
irgendwie nicht so schick irgendwie nicht so geil kann man das xml kann man das xml vielleicht
direkt moment kann man vielleicht das xml direkt editieren hier bootmethode legacy bios ja aber das
kann auch nicht sein dass man das dass man das umstellen muss in leitmanns hyper wie
nein nein hier wird nicht nicht wie wir werden nicht entleitet durch hyper wie
du kriegst es 1024 mb meinetwegen also ich weiß ich also das bin ich der mein das muss
funktionieren ansonsten ist irgendwas grundsätzlich kaputt die bootorder war es nicht war es nicht
klicken ist jetzt noch mal schnell durch oder ist nicht das problem das wird das wird trotz
zl rom einfach funktionieren united states amerikan ist mir doch egal einfach einfach weiter
und das nicht zugreifen können standardmäßig auf die dienste die da drauf laufen ist auch doof
also ich muss sagen man muss da relativ viel aufpassen dass man das richtige macht und dann
auch ein bisschen da rum basteln von hand also insgesamt gefällt es mir eigentlich ganz gut
auch das web interface punktet schon irgendwo aber ich sehe es mich jetzt nicht lokal verwenden
anub sicher ist es nicht was
nur sicher ist es definitiv nicht
ja aber manchmal brauchst du halt vms zum beispiel home assistant betreibt man am besten in der vm
unabhängig davon ich weiß dass es das als helm chart gibt aber das ist naja fragwürdig also
ich finde home assistant ist in der vm immer noch das beste wie man es betreiben kann allein
schon weil du dann die ganzen home assistant plugins gescheit verwenden kannst ja und so
device pass per usb in so einer vm ist auch easy und dann kann sich home assistant drum kümmern also
ist schon eine sinnvolle geschichte und das handling ist jetzt nicht so geil bis jetzt
wo ist der unterschied zwischen docker und helm chart helm chart ist also ganz simpel gesagt ja
helm chart ist ein installations skript für kubernetes wie du anwendungen in dein kubernetes
cluster installieren kannst so package manager nennen sich offiziell aber es ist eher ist
eigentlich eher so ein install skript was kubernetes ressourcen anlegt und applied im cluster
no will ich nicht extra scannen ja ja weiter weiter weiter ja und docker ist
linux container frontend ja aber das so nice dass das will ich nicht ich will nicht trunas
in proxmox dann haben nur dass ich ein web interface für laufwerk shares hab und sowas
deswegen finde ich das mit unrate auch wie gesagt ich weiß dass ich am anfang ein bisschen
gebasht hab eigentlich ganz gut
wahrscheinlich ist im heimbereich so ein zynology nass wirklich noch das
einfachste wenn man keinen bock hat sich da irgendwie mit was zu beschäftigen das einfachst
und auch das wirklich einzigste für wenns wenns nub sicher sein muss oder halbwegs nub sicher mit
vielen features
bei zynology hat man leider keine vms doch oder das ging doch früher
da haste da vms da wird schön machine manager klar
installation ist komplett ok der verkackt der verkackt ist wohl mit docker
pass mal auf jetzt wurde er wieder nicht ja ok also das mit vms kannst vergessen
da damit hat es bei mir schon mal verloren was kannst du dann schon mal vergessen also wenn
er fern sich ordentlich funktionieren klar man kann es jetzt auf bios umstellen und sowas aber
das ist halt das ist halt unsinnig die proxmox proxmox eignet sich für meinen anwendungsfall
daheim nicht gut edit aber das geht jetzt natürlich nicht wenn ich im efe mode installiert
habe naja das ist doof also die vm vm handling gefällt mir nicht so wie löscht man es jetzt
das ist kein bsd mehr ne das ist mittlerweile linux
ich glaube das hat jetzt als übersicht eigentlich ganz gut gereicht von der zeit her ist es 22
passt auch wunderbar wunderbar dass das viel ram und cpu fressen soll ja gut guck mal das
zeug hat halt auch einen gewissen management overhead was wenn es start ist hast ja erst mal
mindestens zehn verschiedene management container am start ja also was soll ich sagen es ist
insgesamt es hat sowohl hat mich auf der einen seite hat es einen guten eindruck gemacht auf der
anderen seite nicht so einen guten eindruck schwer zu sagen also die vm funktionalität gefällt mir
gar nicht dass es doch dass es ein kubanitas ist mit docker mit helm chart frontend ist eine
gute idee eigentlich irgendwie logisch das finde ich ist eine coole sache das problem ist nur wenn
irgendwas nicht startet du kannst doch dem 015 user dann nicht zumuten dass der dann sich per ssh
verbindet mit kubectl und sonst was so ein single node kubanitas cluster debugde bis das scheiß
wieder funktioniert ne es kommt nicht gleich mit android also muss ich sagen für muss ich sagen
da liegt für mich android jetzt immer noch vorne bei den lösungen
android hat eine gute kombination aus features und einfachen benutzen was halt dummer an android
ist dass die bei manchen sachen lahm as fuck sind was fixen mit den docker problemen und so was
oh tunas kakuate tunas wieder weg android bekommt auch zfs ja wie gut da das frontend sein wird sein
wird das mal dahingestellt weil ganz im ernst dass android frontend ist bestenfalls ok also
preis gewinnt nie für das frontend nicht aber ich finde den ich finde die feature kombination
jetzt weg finde ich finde die feature kombination ganz gut
leute ich gehe ins bett wir sehen uns mal gut bis denn zu bett geteim
wir haben es noch nicht fertig gemacht wir haben es noch nicht fertig gemacht ich musste dann
mmo kreisel crime machen gehen vielleicht sollten wir das auch demnächst vielleicht
sollten wir das demnächst mal fertig machen harvest das ist rancher zeug oder nee oder
oder was ist was ist das ich pränen sie mit mit rancher in verbindung im hinterkopf
ganz ehrlich die nass funktionalität für den heimbereich in android ist komplett in
ordnung kannst mit zwei klicks den share anlegen ja du meinst du meinst das rancher
harvester ding alles da leute wir sehen uns bis denn zu